欢迎大家回到我们这个就是内卷之王
就是老师和同学们一起卷的这个卷王之王的课
那么过去一个星期的话
我们又终于卷完了我们的渲染的最后一节课
其实呢在前面的几趴的时候
我们跟同学们讲我们的课程的时候
我们也看到很多同学们的反馈
然后的话呢就有些同学讲
说我们这很多的课程的东西
数据量就是那个算法量特别大
很多很多的算法
然后很多算法大家都听不懂
其实这个当时我也看到了
我也在一直在想这个问题
其实这里面的话我想跟大家分享一下
我自己这边的观点
就是说其实我在准备这个课程的时候
我们课程组的话其实也非常的纠结
因为如果我们讲一些比较简单的
比较基础的算法的话呢
实际上它是能很容易把大家讲明白的
而且呢我一个算法假设留20分钟左右
那么它出现的问题是什么
就是这些算法实际上在行业里面
大家已经基本上不怎么去用了
那实际上他已经有点absolute了
第二个就是我一直在思考
就是说games104克到底它的定位是什么
我的理解它像一个通识课
什么意思呢
就是说其实游戏引擎啊
它真的是一个非常非常博大精深的一个
就是啊计算机软件系统
它几乎涵盖了计算机科学所有的知识
其实在全球
我觉得能够完整地知道
就是现游戏引擎的所有的知识点
和方方面面的东西的人
应该是非常非常屈指可数的
也就是说这样的话
大家想象一下
如果这么难
那么我们怎么可能通过一个就是零基础
通过一个20个课时的课程
我就能够听懂游戏引擎里面几乎所有的东西呢
这个其实在是实际上是做不到的
其实不只是游戏引擎了
就是游戏
你们就单独指一个东西
比如说渲染
其实就如果我们找到一个计算机图形学的
这个同学的话
他能够把游戏渲染的所有的功能
全部都能想得明白
理解了透
实际上都已经是非常非常的难
所以当时在我去思考这门课的时候
我认为这门课它的核心是帮助大家建立概念
建立知识体系
那么让大家去理解
这就是我一直在前面的课程给大家讲
就是说哎你不用特别care那个公式
那公式看不懂很正常
因为那个公式你真的要去推它
真的要去理解它
比如说积分
你们每个积分项
首先你的数学基础要够好
但这个不重要
我相信很多同学都是有
这个就是大学的高等数学的基础
但是的话呢你真的去理解
那整个每一个光学的那个工具方程式的话
你可能提前要花一一周
甚至一周以上的时间去读那些的方程
那么为什么我讲公式不重要
重要的是什么呢
是思想
因为你理解的这个思想
这些方法的思想的话
其实在你未来的工作中的话
可以举一反三
其实我们在我想象一下
我们104课程的很多同学的话呃
就大家将来真正去做游戏引擎开发的是很少数
但是如果你真的理解了游戏引擎设计的
遇到各种各样的问题
他选择了各种各样解决的方法的话
实际上在你实际的未来的工作开发中的话
你很容易的就可以举一反三
那么其实这个东西的话
不仅仅是对于我们的这个
比如说将来你成为游戏的影游戏开发
还包括比如说你可能是technical artist
就是那个一一就是那个TECHNR的技术美术
你甚至是自己做一些
比如说我可能是WEBGL
或者是数字孪生的一些项目
实际上这些方法论对大家都是很有帮助的
那么我怎么去定位games104这个课程呢
我就觉得这门课程我们用两二十个小时的时间
帮大家建立
最正就是我们尽我所能
对行业的这个就是比较主流的一些方法的
这个解决问题的方法
包括它的整个一个知识体系
然后呢
这样为大家未来的这个学习的话做好基础
而且呢我以前是做科研嘛
其实我我有一个经验
就是我在那个时候
我老师经常让我去读那个前沿的科研论文
那个真的是很难读
真的我可以花一天时间只读一个算法
你都读不懂
但是后来我发现一个办法
就是说如果有一个人告诉我说
诶这个文论文它实际上就是核心点
就这三点
然后呢当我听到了这这个三点的点播之后
我再去读这个论文的话
我的速度就会快非常非常多
因为我知道我该看的是什么
我该忽略的细节是什么
所以其实这也是我们的games104课程的话
我最想给大家传递的一个东西
另外一个就是说大家不要急
其实很多知识啊我们听到了放在脑脑子里面
你当时不明白
但是也许几年后你在做另外一件事情的时候
诶
突然你在104这个课程上
建立了这样的一个印象
这样的一个知识的这个方法
一下子就能蹦跶出来
所以我在我其实我自己在读书治学的时候啊
实践上我以前很信奉一个方法叫囫囵吞枣
就是说你先大量的吸收知识
然后呢吸收一遍
再吸收两遍
不懂没关系
然后我再去实践
当我在实践中遇到一个卡点的时候
我会突然发现
当时我好像听过一句话
我一下子茅塞顿开了
所以的话这就是说啊
这是我自己作为这个课程的这个
这个主导创造者的话
我自己对这个课程的一个理解
就是大家怎么去理解games104课程的逻辑
他的逻辑就是说
帮大家建立一个整个的知识体系
大家听不懂没有关系
公式看不明白也没有关系
但是的话呢你一定要就是听懂这些方法
听懂它的整个一个知识结构
以及人们怎么把这些知识串在一起
你这样建立了一个现代引擎的知识的全部体系
所以在这个这一节课开始之前的话
我先啰嗦这么一段
因为这个因为我发现
其实后台我们同学们反应还是蛮热烈的
我知道大家有压力
但是的话呢我们一定会就是说
既能保证同学们能知道上面的体系
同时的话呢我们也会让大家能入得了手
能够落得了
就是能够做得了的东西
那就是我们的小引擎
后面会讲到
那么今天的话呢
实际上是我们的渲染的最后一节课
实际上前三节课啊
我相信同学们压力很大
我自己压力也很大
然后我们基本上把这个真的是
把一个至少30~40个课程的东西吧
压缩到了四个课程
但这个是OK的
因为实际上这一课
因为我们讲的是整个游戏引擎嘛
所以rendering这一趴的话
帮助大家建立就是渲染的游戏
渲染的基础概念
大家千万不要轻视这里面所点的每一个技术
因为这里的每个技术都是经过很多个
就是成百甚至上千的优秀的工程师
他们在实践中总结出来的这些方法
所以它真正的价值就在这个地方好
那今天的话呢我们开始第四节课
那我先一开始呢
从一个相对比较简单的东西开始
那就从我们的这个AMBULLOCUTION
就大家看到这个场景
这个场景是没有任何渲染
没有任何shading的
就是没有材质的
他让大家看到没有
就是你会看到非常清晰的结构空空间感
这里面有很多的那个几何的细节
那么它实际上在广场中
表现出了一定的明暗关系
这个明暗关系呢和我们传统的明暗关系不一样
它实际上是你会发现诶有个小凹槽
它就显得比较黑对吧
那么有个小突出它就比较亮
这个很符合我们生活中的这个实践
这种细节的光影变化呢
实际上也是满足凯基亚的光照方程
但是呢它实际上在渲染的时候
是非常难以做到的
为什么
因为它这个结构非常的小
我们在计算机同学里面一般叫做myself structure
就中尺度的这个结构
那么当在他对整个天光都在进行照明的时候
你会发现它表面的几何细节会有相应的响应
那么AO这个效果呢在平时大家可能注意不到
但实际上在现代游戏渲染中的话呢
AO的效果是非常明显的
给大家看一个例子
这是一个场景
大家看到这里面用了pp r材质
用了很很漂亮的光照
看着很好看
对不对
但是其实这张图里面缺了AO效果
那现在的话呢我们把AO效果一打开
大家发现没有
就是说这个图
一下子就有非常强的这个立体感了
因为人眼对空间的结构的感知机
完全是基于我们大脑的深度学习的结那个基础
所以我们大脑对这种光影的明暗的变化
是非常敏感的
而且我们可以根据这个光影的明暗变化
构建了我们一个3D视觉
就比如说大家一直以为
3D视觉是基于这个双眼BAROCULAR双目嘛
对是的
双目是一个很重要的
就是空间立体感的perception的一个基础
但是你即使只有一张图的话
我们人也可以在大脑中构建出一个
非常有立体感的东西
那就要通过这个光影变变化
而在这个光影变化里面的话
ambient cushion就是环境光照
那么呃这个好像不是黄金广场
我都不知道中文翻译翻译什么话
我们一般叫AO吧
就是那么它实际上的话呢
是一个非常重要的一个视觉元素
其实在很计算机图形学
到我们游戏渲染很早期的时候
大家就意识到了这个AO的重要性
比如说在我们去渲染那个他的数学原理
刚才也提到
就是说实际上就是对于我的表面上的每一个点
那么他在它的可看见的正半球面的话
它只有部分能够看见天光
有些部分被他周围的几何给遮挡住了
所以呢就会产生了我们的AO的这个效果
那么这个东西有点像什么呢
大家还记得我们在前几课讲那个COOKTOYS的
那个材质模型
就是BRDF表面上很多小面片
它有个选项叫geometry对吧
就是他讲的是几何的自遮挡
其实你没有发现
这个AO跟那个几何字上是不是很像
实际上这个呢如果你把相机拉拉的足够远的话
那这个AO所表现出的数学方程的话
其实你会发现他和那个B2DF是非常接近的
所以我就讲就是尺度它是相对的
就是取决于我们相机的远近好
那么其实呢AO这个效果是非常重要的
那么在最早期的时候呢
我们的做法是比较简单和粗暴的
那就是哎我们比如说做一个角色
实际上这个角色我们在就是大家知道
在ZBRUSH
ZBRUSH里面
我们去雕他们那个高精度模型的时候
是有很多很多细节的
比如像这个人的皱纹啊
他眼角的东西
但是呢一旦我们把它变成游戏里面消耗的
用的那个模型
就是说是低精度的模型的时候
这些细节我们全部把它烘培到那个法向上去了
但是法向呢它只是一种明暗的变化
它实际上不能告诉你几何的变化
而且呢在做渲染的时候
我们实质上也不能够表现出这种诶
就是因为你凹进去了
所以呢你周围的天光看不懂比较少的效果
所以呢在现代的
比如说很多建模软件里面
他都提供了一个叫AO烘培的东西
就像刚才这个老人的脸
如果我们把它烘焙成这个AO图的话
你会发现诶就是这样的一个图
这个图看着有点吓人啊
这个其实你们如果看所有的这个游戏的资
资产图的话
无论是帅哥美女
你去看他的贴图的时候
就看见一张脸被拉得很丑很丑
所以说帅哥美女再漂亮
摊在哪儿都是很都是很恐怖的
那么当当我们有了这样的一张AO的
在渲染的时候加上去的时候
你会发现这个画面右边的那个角色
他的表现感觉完全不一样
那么这种PRECOMPUTER的AO啊
实际上在游戏行业里面
十几年前可能更早就已经在用起来了
而且呢效果是非常的好
直到今天
我们接下来会讲一些更多的real time的计算
AO的方法
但是呢这个方法还是不能被取代掉
为什么呢
因为我们的AO计算都是基于你有几何的
如果你没有几个
就是你的你的表面的
没有真的真真真真切切的那些小的结构的话
我就算real time的方法我也是算不出来的
所以这个方法目前在很多character
就是角色的表达的时候
我们还是很重要的一张图
如果就像我们在上一节课讲到
就是大家如果画一个角色的时候
那么AO这张图的话
一般来讲会出现在你的资产里面好
这是我们最简单的就是用预计算的方法
我记得我们在我们的课程一直在讲
这个思想是什么
就是凡事不取一计算
什么意思
就是说用空间换时间对吧
我在离线的算好
存储在那
那我在real time的时候
我只需要去直接三里就可以了
这也符合我们空间换时间的思想
那么但是的话呢
你现在只能表达一个一个的物体
但是我整个给你一个environment的时候
你会发现诶这个好像不行
因为比如说我一个桌子放在这个地板上
旁边有个椅子
桌子和椅子的位置一直在变呢
那我没有办法在地板上pre bake
就是预先烘培好它的AOCAOAO的效果
对不对
这个肯定是不对的
那怎么办呢
其实这个方法有一个很简单的方法
这个方法呢我先介绍给大家
介绍一个最基础的方法
叫screen space ambinclusion
叫ASSO
今天的话呢同学们一定要记住很多缩写
就是在图形学
计算机的图形学
和这个我们的这个这个游戏的渲染里面的话呢
黑化是特别多的
全是缩写
比如说SSLO就是指的是screen space
Ambient occlusion
这个听上去非常的高大上啊
但其实他的思想是非常简单的
就是说诶
你既然我我从我我的一个相机渲染过去
我就会得到我的一个场景
对不对
得到我的一生图像
一种图像我们看到的是颜色对吧
这个RGB的颜色其实不止一张
图像里面还有什么呢
还有它的深度信息
如果我们把每个像素点的深度信息
连到一起的话
那是不是就是一个high field
大家还记得我们上节课讲地形是high field
对不对好
那如果我知道一个height field
那实际上我实事实上它就是一个几何
我是不是就可以估算这个height field
对它的各个就是它的每一个区域的自制导的
自自制导的关系是什么样子的
那么他就这么一个简单的思想
那怎么做呢
其实比较简单
就是说哎我从这个眼睛射出去
一根光线交到了我看见物体的任何一个点
我知道它在三维空间的XYZ
对不对好
我给您一个半径
我在它的半径的周边
随机的在球形球形的这个空间里面啊
随机的撒若干个采样点
那这个若干的采样点的话呢
我再用相机去投投射
其实我就知道它的深度那么好
它的深度如果比如说我这个采样点
它的深度比我现在在z buffer里面的深度要更近
说明什么意思
说明哎我这个采样点是在可以看得见光的地方
对不对
那如果我的这个深度的话
比现在Z8分的更远
说明什么呢
它一定被当前汇制中的某一个几何给挡住了
对吧
所以这里面一个很重要的思想是什么
这也是我们今天课程反复会出现的
就是screen space
就是啊其实我们虽然在游戏里面
对整个世界有一个完整的几何表达
但是呢我们在做很多运算的时候
如果你真的把那上万个物体对吧
上百万的面片做各种各样的几何运算
它的效率是非常低的
后来大家就发现就说哎我在屏幕上
因为我有深度了
其实我就得到了很多
就是只是对这个世界一个局部采样的几何信息
用这个局部采样的几何信息呢
其实我们可以做很多的因素啊
所以今天我们讲的第一个技术叫screen space
Ambient cushion
就是利用这个原理
其实后面呢我们会提到
比如说screen screen space
shadow map对吧
Screen space reflections
screen space gi这些这些放东西的话呢
实际上都是从这个原始思想出来的
那我们今天先不展开
我们先讲SALO那么好
这个时候实际上当我比如说我是踩了呃
60个点对吧
随机的那中间假设有32个点可见的话
那是不是就意味着说哦我明白了
我大概有一半的空间是被挡住了
所以我的光枪只有它的一半
所以他就给出了一个非常简单的方程
就是这个我多少个采样点N个
然后呢我有有这个讴歌被ACUTION格被挡住了
那我可以看见的光强就是一减它的分子分母
这是他screen space amiddle ution的话
最古老的一个方程
实话实说呢
这个想思想是非常好的
甚至有人专门实践过
但是的话呢说实话
我觉得这个这个方程可能是错的
这个方式错在很多很多地方
那其中第一个我自己当年看的时候
我最诟病的东西就是说大哥
你这不对吧
因为我的一个面能接受光的话
它实际上不是一个完整的球
是一个半球面对吧
那你现在的话如果给我按个点去采样的话
那么假设你是个完整的平面的话
你是不是一定有按概率分布
有一半的点是在那个下半球面的
对不对
那你就是本来平面上应该是没有AO的效果的
大家想想
平面是不是所有的光强我都能看得见对吧
但是按这个工程方方程的话算出来
你就是个1/2了
所以这个这个方程现在用的人应该非常少
而且其实大家都意识到这个方程是有问题的
那么很遗憾就是我现在找到他
那paper上语文真好
他真的是这么写的
当然有人他已经意识到这是他加了个0.5
但这个不重要
重要的是
我觉得大家首先要理解就是screen space这个想法
包括我在这个
以我每一个就是眼睛射出去的像素
我对它进行一个立体空间的采样
这个思想是非常重要的
好那这里面的话呢大家已经意识到了
说我这个采样是多余的
因为我只需要踩半球面
所以呢基于这个思想
我们呢就引入了另外一个方法
就是A我们只需要如果我知道你的法向朝向
我是不是沿着你的法向
只需要踩半个小半个半球
所以呢就有一个改进算法
我们一般传统叫做SSLO的加plus
就是它的加法
那这样的话你的采样点就可以少一半对吧
而且能解决刚才我讲的那个artifacts
他的那个问题
所以说啊最早期的SO的话
据说跑起来的话
整个画面直接就全部给你按按了
也没给你解释为什么是这样
但现在我们知道
其实可能是数学生出了一点问题
好这个方法呢是非常的简单
但是呢你说它好不好用也蛮好用的
比如说像这个结果
这是一个就是有SSAO的结果
那就是没有的
然后大家看一下哎
有了之后你发现整个它的立体感就很好
但这个方法呢其实有很多的问题
比如说你们看那个交通
那个那个那个那个就是那个水泥灯
他那个背后那个地面上出现了很强的那个
AO的效果
那个AO效果其实是错误的
为什么呢
因为它实际上那个离它已经很远了
它不应该对地面产生那么强的AO效果
但是呢在屏幕空间中
它没有办法区分这件事情
所以它会产生一个就是我们叫做artifact
就是说一个不应该出现的一个重影
所以这就是一个简单算法
他所付出的代价好
那后面的人呢就会不停的去改进它
那我们继续看另外一个算法
这个叫HBL这个方法呢
其实他就已经部分解决了我们讲的问题
他说哎
你现在不就是说要求一个在这个球面空间上的
你的可见性吗
那么我实际上从这个点出发的话
我沿着各个方向去转
我去找一个
就是他光线能越过他那个最高的那个邻居
几何的那个叫我们叫做叫peach angle
就是向上的那个仰角
大家这个怎么解释呢
就是说假设我现在出现了AO
我就在一个山谷里面
那好我就问一个问题
假设我射一束光
我这时光的就是仰角要多高
能够越过这
我现在能看到的那个就是仰角最高的那个山脊
对吧
我要越过它的山脊
实际上他就去找那个点
那么如果我在周边的这一圈的
这个点都找到的话
我是不是就可以得到一个
在这个就是我们的右上角那个图上
有一个
就是那种诶高高低低的那样的一个覆盖图
那你知道这个球形空间的这个仰角的
这个采样的话
实际上我们是不是就能估算出来
说有多大的面积的天顶
它是可见的
有多大面积的
那个就是那个就是那个面积是被遮挡住的
实际上就是用一个很简单的一个
你可以理解为这个离散积分的思想好
但这里面的话呢它就引入了一个hack
他加了一个叫attenuation的方式方程
就是说如果啊那个山离我太远了
我认为他对我的AO没有什么变化
刚才我讲的那个artifact
对不对
那大家想想看
这个地方我的距离如果设计的比较短的话
是不是就会那个地方就是那个W它就变成零了
所以就不会出现说其实距离你一个很远的物体
但是呢它还显示在我那边产生了个AO
所以HBO的话呢
它实际上就是一下子又解决了这个问题
那这个问题的话呢
它实际上它的结果呢相对来讲就更好一点
但具体怎么做的呢
这里面就有很多的细节
但今天我的细节不展开了
你可以你需要大家需要知道的东西是什么呢
就是说它实际上用的是一个叫REMARCH
它又又是一个REMARIN的算法
Marching
大家还记得吗
就是诶我一个像素一个像素的掌握
当然它是有个步长了
它不是一那个一个一个像素
但是呢它就会从那个点出发
他那个当然它的它的方向
它在每个每个每个点的时候
它会稍微坚持一下
就是要变一下
为什么呢
因为如果我每次找的这个方向都是一致的话
你会发现因为你采样率很低啊
它会出现一些很明显的一些就是ALEX的花纹
就是大家如果学过信号和系统
就知道
就是说如果我对一个信号采样率特别低
而且我采样的那个滤波气它是非常规整的话
那你滤出来的信号它本身是有很明显的pattern
所以呢他就加了个hack
说我加了一个JRAN
然后呢我就在那个pixel shader里面
我一步一步沿着刚才我讲的时候
你的z buffer给你生成的那个
你可以理解成一个后面的一个height field
我去找我最远的那个攻角是多少
这样我就可以找一圈
我就可以算出我的值
这就是HBAO的这个核心的想法
所以呢这个HBO的话呢
它实际上就是说它是基于一个半球面的一个
积分的这样的一个想法
这个想法实际上它的结果的话
实际上是比刚才我讲的SAO的效果要好很多
二技能解决这个artifacts
但是呢这个HBO的话呢
实际上它还是有它的算法上
一个很核心的问题呢
这个问题是什么呢
就是大家还记得我们在前面讲材质的时候
大家想象一下我们天空还是个球
对不对
从假设我的表面
大家想的最简单的情况
我是朝上的
那我从四面八方照过来的光
大家想想
他从天顶上射下来的光和从这边射下来的光
它的贡献值是一样的吗
同学们
还记得我们在前面讲一个漫反射模型里面
有一个叫NUMBERATION的这个模型对吧
实际上在南边是模型里面
有一个很重要的因素是什么呢
是个扩散
因此什么意思
就是说你的光越是靠近靠近天顶的时候
假如那个角叫theta啊
他cos cos theta为零的时候
那你的IRRADIANCE
就是你射出来的强度是百分之百的
被我这个表面给吸收了
然后呢我的反射是怕四面八方均匀的反射
所以说OK这是没有区别
所以无论你从什么地方看
你看到的都是百分之百的强度
没问题
就是反射的就反射的强度百分之百好
但是同样亮度的光
假设是以这个比如说斜45度射过来的话
他的那个就是实际上就反射出来的光
是不是那个扩散
现在也就是cos45度
Cos45
大概是二分之根号二吧
大概0.7左右
所以刚才他们在算那个球的面积的时候
就是在H
就其实在那个HABO和那个SSAO的时候
实际上呢他们都没有考虑这个因子
所以他们算出来那个值啊全是错误的
那么这就说了
就这也是现在大家用的最多的
叫GTAO
GTO这个AO这个名字取得是非常的霸气的
叫ground truth
Based ambient occlusion
ground truth呢是一个行业的通用语
就是说我和真实的值
或者叫我的基准参考值是一致的
ground truth一般我不知道怎么翻译啊
就是就叫做正确值吧
或者说叫做我的这个参考正确值
也就是说他climb我的AO是符合
这个
就是真真正的
这个你你用那个离线算法算出来的结果
确实他的论文中也给出了这个demo
就是说诶你会发现我们渲染的结果
和你和那个就是用蒙托卡罗积分
然后非常慢的去做的结果几乎是一样的
那么这里面的话就等于说
其实他真的把这个你表面的法向考虑进去了
那这样的话我就知道
当你的光从各方面来的时候
你斜过来的那个天顶的那个
就是权重是要被打折的
你靠近天顶的那个面积是非常
贡献度是非常大的
所以大家去只要理解这个思想就可以了
那么这里面的话呢
其实在这个ground truth a o里面
还有一个非常厉害的地方
这也是我个人觉得他们是非常聪明的地方
也特别希望大家能掌握思想的地方
就是说他们意识到一件事
就是说如果我们能算出来这个东西
就是它的AO值是多少
我能不能猜一下这个光射进来之后
在这里面来回bounce
就是我们叫multi scattering
最后形成的亮度是多少
大家想想看
因为现在AO的话只是说光挡住了
挡住了
光射到另外一边
那么的话呢它你看不见它就没有共享
但实际上跟真实的物理效果是不一样的
对不对
真实的物理效果
实际上你可以看到它的那个就是说呃
就是说还是会就来回在那个
就是假设你个山谷光射到山谷的另外一侧
你在山谷底照射是最黑的地方对吧
但实际上因为山谷两侧的反光
你实际上那个底没有那么黑
对不对
而且还有一点就是这个里面的颜色的话
跟我山谷的周边的颜色是有关
比如说我讲解这个山谷这边是绿的
这边是红的
那我这个股在这个山谷里面看到那个眼
那个AO的那个颜色是不是带色相的
这个听上去是不是很复杂对吧
我们是不是要做很多的积分才能得到这个结果
但是呢这也是GTAO
我认为他这个名字叫gt
那个里面一个非常好的一个想法
他这个老哥做了一件什么事情呢
就是说它根据你不同的AO值
实际上比如说0.60.4
0.20.3
他做了一个就是大量的
大家现在如果学机器学习的话
他就做大量的分析
对这个数值进行分析
他发现就是说啊
你的这个AO值实际上和你的multi scans值
实际上是有一定的关联度的
这个关联度当然不是一个简单的线性的
然后呢他发现它里面符合了某一条曲线
然后这个曲线呢这个老哥就很厉害
给出了一个就是polynomial的
就是一个多项式的方程
这个方程呢大概是三阶的
你就可以用一个多项式计算
你就能够根根据你的这个就是现在的AO值
我能估算出来
光在你们来回boss最终的结果
这个听上去是不是非常的神奇
觉得卧槽
这这简直就是就像我经常讲的
就是那个还记得在上一节课
我讲那个fog的时候
就讲那个最新的那个就是那个fog的方法的话
实际上他就是只算了一次的
这个这个就是那个啊光的in那个single scattering
但是呢我觉得那个approximate multi screen
他两个思想是不是有异曲同工之妙
那这件事情到底有没有道理呢
其实我个人觉得就是
他虽然在原来的原来的论文中
没有给出这个理论证明啊
但是其实我个人觉得他是在数学上是有基础的
因为大家想想看
我们在算那个就是BRDF模型的时候
我们其实也并不知道他那个微表面上有很多
很多的细节结构
对不对
但是我们用了一个统一的量叫做RAGHNESS
roughness呢
就表达了它的几何的不平整度对吧
大家想想看这里的AO那个值的话
是不是有点像那个小区域的roughness的值
也就表示了我周围对我的遮挡性
就是有点像BTM的那个G
如果你假设在这个表面上分布
大家基本上符合一个统计学分布的话
实际上你用统计学的方法去算的话
这里面肯定是有一个关联度的
但这个关联度可能是个积分值
可能是个更复杂的方程
但是呢你再复杂的方程在某些情况下
你可以用一个比如说多项式去拟合它
这个在数学上也是成立的
所以我个人觉得就是说gt a o的这个discovery
就是这个这个observer就是他这个发现啊
我认为它是有数学的foundation的
所以同学们
如果有人对这个东西特别感兴趣的话
我会觉得大家可以深入研究一下
因为对于我们的graphics engineer来讲的话
我就觉得哇很厉害
你就用这个方法来解决了
那这也是回到我刚才在课程一开始讲的东西啊
就是虽然我在这里面跟大家讲一个算法
其实本身作为一个GTO这个算法的话呢
我不需要花这么多久
这么久跟大家去讲
但是呢我个人觉得他的这个思想特别的好
就是从最开始的就是大家做SAO
就是想到了用screen space方法对吧
我不用对整个世界进行几何的运算
到这个HPAO呢
你可以认为它是一个过渡性的一个产品
那么到了GTAO的话呢
是从数学上彻底的把这个问题给解掉了
同时的话呢
他还观察到了一个很重要的一个性质
然后呢给出了一个拟合方程
这样的话一下子让我们的AO的效果
就是从一个简单的这种黑白分明
变成了有彩色有色相的这样的一个效果
所以我个人是蛮喜欢这个这个这个这个算法的
那么呃哎哟我这边少了两张图
其实我本来有一张那个GTAO的
这个前后的图
其实特别在他给出了一个人脸
一个一个一个人的皮肤的渲染
效果是非常的好的
那么AO的话呢
因为我今天的课程有限
所以我不讲了太多
希望大家注意的就是现在还有一个比较
现在慢慢越来越火的一个方向
就是real time retracing amazon clusion
那这个大家都知道
大名鼎鼎的这个这个这个RTX对吧
就是我们所有人游戏没有return tron
好像都不是这个时代的游戏了
那么既然rotary tracing的数学
基础的核心是什么呢
就是说现在GPU能够帮助你快速的做一个
recasting的这样的一个计算
告诉你说你到底有没有hit到
那么实际上我对屏幕上的每个像素我可以设ray
然后他知道我跟周围有没有遮挡
但这里面呢其实有很多的细节
今天我不展开了
就实际上在如果你想做对的话
实际上你应该在屏幕上的每个像素点
在他的半球面射出很多关锐
对不对
但是呢既是地主家
他也不能这么造
就是说你现在的GPU也不能跑的那么快
所以呢他真实的做法是在每一帧的时候
对于每个像素大概只对外设一一到两根瑞
但是呢他在这个时序上进行了一个
这个数据的收集
这样的话能够完成这样的一个球面的一个
采样的近似
这里面有很多的细节
所以今天在这课程我不展开
但是我希望同学们关注这个方向的发展
所以AO的话呢基本上大家看到GTAO
看到retracing ammaccretion的话
基本是现在大家比较前沿的一个
AO的一个方向
好了我们有了这个AO了
那接下来呢给大家讲一个
也是非常好看的一个效果
叫做fog
叫误校对吧
负
我觉得物小时
基本上所有同学都会注意到的一个效果
那么fog呢其实它的原理啊
最最开始的这个
在游戏里面用的是非常非常简单的
我们叫做depth fog
它就简单来讲就是从你的眼睛看出去
然后呢随着距离你的透明度逐渐的下降
那么大家想的最简单的方法是什么
linear fog对吧
就是说我用这个线性的方法
就是从一般这种fog我们会设置一个起始点
比如说特别近的地方
我们还是希望没有bug看得清楚啊
逐渐逐渐fork起来
然后到了一定远处
这个fog就到了它的最大值
然后呢但是呢实际上在大家用的过程中呢
我们会发现诶用指数型fog是特别比较好对吧
然后的话呢大家一般喜欢用
就是二阶的指数型fog
这个里面是非常非常简单的max
如果今天大家打开任何一个商用引擎吧
如果你选择那个fog
它最缺省的最简单的模式就是这个fog模式
大家如果打开unity的话
你可以看到我们这边的三种模式
就是linear fog
Exponential fog
exponential那个squad fog
其实在里面都是你的选项
他的数学基础也是非常的简单
基本上就是我们的高中数学吧
但是呢这个fog呢
实际上对世界的表达力还是有限的
我再举个例子
就是说大家看这个我们在真实践
你们会发现
就经常这个fog它实际上是有一个高度的
这个是原因很简单
就是fog它是一个气溶胶对吧
它实际上呢很多时候会沉淀在靠近地面的地方
特别是我们在爬山的时候
我们会发现诶我爬上山顶的时候是没有fog的
但是我在山脚下的时候
我是有fog对吧
那包括就比如说我们在游戏里面
营造一种很恐怖的场景
比如说这是一个大猎物
然后下面跑的都是这种什么什么有毒的东西
然后下面有一层毒雾
然后呢你站在那个裂谷上面
看下去那个下面的场景
所以这个时候就是也是一个非常常用的效果
叫做HIFK
那HEDFG呢就是在计算机图渲染里面的话呢
他的假设是这样的
就是我的fog是有一个就是说哎最大值
就是当这个高度低于某个高度的时候
下面所有的fog都是那个fog的
最大的那个fog值
但是当你的高度高于它的时候呢
我们认为你的fog的那个强度呢
是以指数在递减的好
那这时候我就问题就来了
就是当我一个人站在一个某个特定的高度
比如说那个ZV对吧
就是我的view的这个Z这个V呢
我解释简单一点吧
它比那个fog的高度高一点
我看fog里面的一个东西
那我应该看到那个fog强度是多少呢
大家想想这个问题
这个问题呢其实它不简单
为什么呢
呃他不是一个简单的说
我算那一点的fog是多少
我就我就是算出来的fog
他为什么不能用那个东西去算呢
因为很简单
就是说假设那个点正好是在那个
high fog的最高点的话
是不是从他到我这边来的时候
它的fog的浓度会越来越低
越来越低越来越低
对不对是吧
所以说它不是一个简单的一个匀质的fog
那么大家还记得我们在讲那个
前面讲天空和大气的时候
我们遇到这种事情怎么办
只有REMARCHING进行积分
对不对
所以说那我们只能一步一步的积分
那么其实这个算法呢
就这个效果呢其实很早以前就提出来了
那个时候大家就意识到说对啊
这个地方我确实要想做对的话
我需要对它进行积分
但是那个时候我还没有能力
就是没在pixel shader里面一步步的积分
这个解释在那个那个时代的硬件是要死的
那怎么办
诶大家发现我对他作为一个做了个简化
就是说我认为就是fog intensity
直接对你的fog的那个
就是它的透明度是一个线性相关的
那我就沿着这个路径进行
一个只对你的浓度进行积分
算出你个浓度值
包括算用它来估算你的透明度
这个具体的计算过程呢我就不推荐
因为你会发现啊
这个函数如果都是E的自然对数的一个函数啊
你在对它进行积分求导的时候
你可以求出它的解析解
所以在真实计算的时候呢
你只需要把解释解带进去就可以了
但是这个公式其实是非常简化的
实际上你的眼睛在fog就是那条高面以下
高面以上
你的物体在高面以上
高面以下其实还是有一点点区别的
那么包括就是说你的颜色就in scatter to fog
给你的颜色在这个过程中也是一个积分值
那这里面的话呢就是说有很多小的数学细节
那今天我们就不展开
但是大家要知道知道就是说fog在古典时代
我经常讲古典时代什么
就10年前的3A游戏
基本上DEPLOGHDFG基本够用了
那么但是在现代的话呢
就是我希望大家关注的一个东西
就是说诶基于体系化的这个fog
大家看到这边的效果没有
就是说诶我们的fog开始有这种体量感了
比如说你一道光射出来的时候
我能看到一道道的光柱射出来对吧
这个效果是不是看上去非常的苦
那么很遗憾
就是刚才我介绍的那个就是depth fog
和height fog是实现不了这个效果的
这个效果呢它是用什么方法实现的
它其实实际上是我们把相机空间的整个空间
进行WORKALIZE
大家注意啊
这个WORKSALIZE呢和我们以前讲的均匀的体系化
不太一样
你想空间中经营的体系化
我根据XYZ对吧
我就把他一刀刀切过去
但是大家想想看
从我的人一眼看过去的话
我们是不是在近处的时候
它的很多进步是被浪
就是不够对吧
就是颗粒度太大
但是呢到远处的时候
它的颗粒度又太细了
它实际上就是你产生不到你你想要的效果
所以聪明的这个就是graphics engineer
他们想了个方法是什么呢
就是根据我的视锥诶
以我的镜平面平面
用我的视锥进行切分
大家看到那个上面那个黄色的那个切分图
你会发现就是他在近处
就离你眼睛近的地方切得非常的密
离你眼睛眼睛远的地方切得非常的远
这个时候他在这样的一个不规则的
就是不均匀的这样的
其实它是它是规则的
但是呢它只是不均匀的这样的一个grade里面
进行各种各样的remarching in scattering
multi scussion的这个计算
这个计算的话呢
其实它的方法和我们在上一节课里面讲的
算那个语音核算
那个sky的方法其实是大同小异的
所以说那个如果大家对这个fog
对于这种volumetric的
这种foggy的rendering的感兴趣的话
你其实只要把上一节课里面就是怎么讲
算大气的方法看明白了
你就知道这个fog怎么算了
其实呢你把大型的东西看明白了
你其实就知道那个那个那个语音啊
他是怎么做的了
所以我在讲
就是说我们实际上很很注重跟大家讲这个方法
就是讲这个思路
他的这个思想是一致的
那么大在工程实践中的话呢
我们一般会A构建一个3D的texture来存
这里面所有的中间计算的结果来看
我们一般的分辨率怎么看呢
大家看到这里面这个数字非常有意思啊
比如说我这个3D texture呢是横160
总数是90
然后深度呢可能是64
可能是这个更高一点
大家有没有注意到
为什么它的横竖不是我们在做纹理的时候
经常看到的那个二的幂次方呢
大家仔细看里面发现一个细节没有
就16比九是什么
是不是我们屏幕的resolution
所以呢他这个texture
实际上尽量保持在屏幕上的一个像素块
我对他的采样是一致的
这样的话我这个采样出来的这个
比如说这些线条
这些这些结构看上去才比较好看
所以这是一个非常有意思的一个细节
但是如果大家自己去做的时候
你就知道这个texture
我是resolution
我是不能乱射的好
那么这个就是这个现代fog的话呢
一个比较热门的一个方向
接下来讲一个大家特别不注意不到的东西
就是所以今天我的这个课程标题特别有意思
我就讲个post process
这个render pipeline and everything
就是说因为今天是rendering最后收官的一刻吗
我会讲到很多大家注意不到的东西
但是呢当你在做引擎的时候
这些东西呢又非常有用
它是必须要做的东西
反走样又是我们在渲染的时候特别头疼
又是要特别需要解决的东西
那么走样的话是什么东西呢
其实大家仔细看啊
就是说其实啊我们在绘绘制的时候
不管我的算法显得多高级
最后我是一个像素
一个像素的把这个世界绘出来
对不对
那么每一个像素呢
你可以理解成就是对一个连续的
就是这个世界的一个采样
因为真实世界的这个信号的频率
这个信号的密度是无限高的
对不对
但是我用一个像素
一个像素的去表达它的时候
那我是不是这个采样率是不够的
就像我们一张一个照片
在以前的时候
数字数码相机那个精度不高的时候
我们看到那时候的照片
我们人脸上感觉那个色块很大很多的马赛克
对不对
但现在数码相机的分辨率越来越高的时候
我们发现这个马赛克越来越小了
那么其实aliens的话呢
本质上就是因为我们的屏幕的resolution
他是有限的
而呢我们的要表达的后面的几何世界
它的频率是非常非常高的
那举个例子
它这里面有三大源泉
这是我个人总结的不一定正确
就是说第一个呢就是由几何导致的
比如说我一条一个一个几何的边
它只要不是严格的横平竖直的话
那你在这个屏幕上一个像素一个上踩过去的话
它一定是会产生这种ZC的这个效果的
大家想想是不是
就像刚才我一开始举的那个例子
就是字体的例子的时候哦
它的采样就是不均匀的哦
这个例子在后面
不好意思
那么第二个的话呢
就是说哎我的在这个就是在这个物体系表面
表面
我有很多的细节
比如说texture
那么texture的话呢
它的采样就是当我在不同的角度去看的时候
这个texture就会产生各种各样的artifact
就是就像这个中间那张图展示出来那个摩尔纹
但是texture这个采样的aliens的话呢
是由我们在前面课讲的就是mid map解决了
就是说OK你如果很清晰的看我texture
我就我就直接把你预先filter到了
最核心的那个点啊
最远处的那个mp去了
这样的话你这个效果也没有了
还有一类的A类型资源呢
是大家其实平时注意不到的
就是说实际上对于在场景中
很多高频的就是非常容易变化
所所谓的高频就变化
它的幅度可能很小
但是变化速度非常快的这种东西
比如什么东西呢
高光大家想想看
我拿一个很光亮光亮的东西
当我去动它的时候
它上面的高光流动是不是非常的迅速对吧
我我稍微转一个小小的角度
它的高光就一瞬间就流动了
其实高光也是在游戏里面产生
很重要的一个一个源泉
所以其实这些所有的东西都会让整个游戏
画面变得非常的难看
就是说如果一个现代游戏啊
如果我把他的NTLS给关掉
打开的话
你会觉得是两个游戏关掉之后
你觉得整个眼睛都在闪
我相信很多同学喜欢玩游戏的
都知道我在讲什么对吧
我们在游戏里面那个那个GRAPHX设置里面
经常有你要四倍AA还是这个更大的A
这都是你的选择的对吧
现在一般都是4XA吧
好像是好
那么怎么去这个把这个alien给去除掉呢
这就是我们叫做anti anything
就是跟ALEX作战对吧
这就是刚才我提前讲的那个图
就是说
其实所有的这个就是去除那个alien的方法
它的核心思想都很很很简单
都是一个思想
就是说OK我知道我在屏幕上
每个像素它的采样是不充分的好
那我就多采样几个
就我们一般叫做SUBSAMPLING或者sub pixel
我就多采用几次
那这样我采用出的值的话
它就有变化了
对不对
我把这些变化的值呢
我对它进行一个平均平均之后
虽然我这时候你会你会发现
就是说它不再是那么硬的一个边界
它会产生很多过渡区域
这些过渡区域在一个个像素你看起来的时候
它就显得很光滑
举个例子
像刚才这个字体
以字体为例
就是现在同学们你在电脑里面打的所有的字
他都是true type
出tab是什么呢
它都是矢量的这个字矢量的字的话呢
它的精度是可以无限放大的
对不对
但是它在放大的时候
实际上它的那个你的屏幕的分辨率是一定的
所以如果你仔细去看的话
你会发现诶它最终会形成一个一个ZC的结果
你看到那个这边的那个就是靠啊
左边的这个没有被A类型过的
这个NTA类型过的这个A字
那么但现代计算机在渲染的时候呢
我们一般都会打开NTA型的
所以你如果在电脑上看到那个A的时候
你会发现它的边界不再是一个明确的零一变化
虽然你看起来好像觉得是零一
但实际上他做了很多的这个超采样
让你看到了那种A半透明的那个区域
这个区域你怎么看呢
就大家如果眯起眼睛去看的话
你就能发现诶
那个好像这个右边的这个A
看上去线条更平滑一点
这就是NTA类型
就是我们叫做AA的一个核心的思想和它的效果
那好那在我们的这个渲染中的话
AA这么重要
那我们怎么做呢
先给大家介绍两个非常简单的方法
第一个方法呢叫super sampling的一个ASSA对吧
那这个方法呢它其实是非常的简单和直接的
就是说OK你不就是要超采样吗
假设你现在要绘制一个1024×7
六八的一个图像
对不对
我把你所有的尺寸double一下
好不好
我会这个2048对吧
乘上一个这个E4多少的这样的一个尺寸
然后呢我把这个就是四
这就是传说中4X对不对
我把你这个4X倍大小的这个图像
我把它作为一个当SA对吧
我甚至更高级一点
我做一个小的滤波
Ging filter
诶
我把你变成我下面的那个结果
那么这就是一个A很好的一个anta lien的方法
这个方法呢其实它是一定是work的
但是呢他付出的代价就是说哎呀
我这个无论是我的z buffer呀
还是我的这个frame buffer呀
包括我的所有的pixel shader的渲染呢
都付出了额外的四倍的代价对吧
那么就是说这样的话呢
实际上就意味着说如果我的显卡足够牛逼
那我就用这个SSA
但是呢这个实话实说
好像现在的游戏引擎中
已经很少有人用这个方法了
那么这里面大家就会观察到
一个非常有意思的事情
就是说刚才我们讲了
就是说哎alien产生资源最多的是什么
是发生在这种几何的边缘
对不对
比如说以这边的三角形为例
你会发现啊
如果我想对它进行超采样
你会发现这个三角形中间的大部分的点
其实我不需要进行超采样
为什么它都在我一个三角形内部
对不对
我用中间的那个颜色大致代表一下
应该问题也不大
他真正问题出在什么地方呢
是出在那个诶边界上的点
就是我那个像素
我我站了一点
但又没有完全站
那个时候可能是另外一个三星在那边了
所以呢后人呢又发明了一个叫MASA
叫multi sample a n t a s那个MA的思想呢
其实实际上就非常的简单和淳朴
就是说我虽然对这个空间还是四倍的去采样
但是呢当我在做shading的时候
我会去看说如果我这四个sub3
SUBPIXEL或者叫SUBSAMPLE
都落在同一个节目水
就其实他反射它它它算法的时候是反过来的
是说这个triangle coverage
对这四个采样点是百分之百的话
那我只是一定一次
但是呢如果我在这个四个采样点中诶
不止一个赛团队贡献的话
那我把你们都设定一下
然后我算一下你们的average对吧
根据你们的采样点的占的比例
比如说比如说四个采样点
四个四个四个sub su的点
那两个人各占一半
那好我们讲解二一添作
五一人一半
如果你三我一好
那你就是75%的权重
我就是25%的权重
那么这个方法的话呢
实际上非常的有意思啊
这个方法实际上是啊
现代硬件基很早就已经彻底支持了
所以说当你去做一个游戏研发的时候
你说我打开一个功能叫MSA的话
就是一个flag打开之后
这些所有的计算硬件把你全部做掉对吧
他就不用你再去操心
但是呢这个算法实际上呢他还是要付掉
就是四倍的
这个就是说啊这个这个z buffer
四倍的rust rization的结果
然后呢
就是说它的frame buffer其实也是需要四倍的
但最后的话他会就只是在做pixel shading的时候
他会帮你跳的很多不需要的那种渲染
这个方法其实是非常好的一个方法
但这个方法其实也是有它的问题
它的问题是什么呢
就是说在我们现代游戏下面下面啊
其实我们的这个就是说
我们的几何密度是非常非常高的
就是就像大家我们在后面高级课程跟大家讲
我们的NANA的技术点吧
NANA的技术点是什么
就是我们client说我们在一个场景中
你看到的船购的数量会超过你的像素数量
那么密的三角形的话
大家想想看MCA是不是会彻底彻底的失效
对不对
所以说的话呢这个也是一个非常古老的技术
但这两个技术呢
实际上就是那个SSA和MSA的话呢
你看今天那个术语太多啊
但大家记得就是这个MCASSSSA
你看我这经常会弄混
那么它是一个就是上古时代的一个NTAS的
技术
很简单
但其实还是蛮蛮蛮实用的
但是呢其实也是比较古老的好
其实今天的话呢其实anta lion算法的话呢
实际上有很多很多的变种
但今天呢我只跟大家着重的讲两种
NTA类的算法
因为我个人为什么选这两个方法
第一个是在工业界
现在大家觉得这个方法都特别的好
更重要的一点是什么呢
就是说它代表了两个非常巧妙的思想的
这个方向
那么第一个呢我们叫做FXA
它的它是什么缩写呢
叫ffast approximate antella
从它的名字你可以看出来说
我是一个快速估算的anti的算法
这个方法是什么意思呢
就是说啊你就不要那么笨了
就是把这个采样做大对吧
采样做大学不会啊
我现在就给你原始图像
你有没有本事帮我去做他的NTAC
你看这个问题是不是很难
就是说就像老师说
老板让你把生意做得更好
但是又不给你更多的本钱
这个头很疼对吧
诶但是这个就是这个FXA
他就是说诶我要发挥我的聪明才智
发挥我的主观主观能动性
他怎么做
他说你们在做这个NT类型的时候
不都是在那些边界吗
比如说高光颜色在高速的变化
或者说一个一个三角形
它发生折线
快速的折到另外一边
那其实这个时候会产生什么呢
产生这个颜色的跳变
就是大家如果学过computer vision的话
就是计算机视觉的有个很重要的领域
叫做ag detection
就是我会把这个画图片中的很多edge
给它提取出来对吧
那么他说如果我在这个你生成的这一帧画面中
我帮你把所有的这个A级提取出来
我只在A级的这个地方
我采用一些聪明的差值的方法
我是不是也能产生一个这个反走样的效果呢
唉这帮人说干就干
他首先干第一个事
就是用了一个非常简单的十字形滤波
就是说啊我对于每个像素点
我把你的这个左右邻居上下邻居加在一起
我去算你的这个这个差异值
当你的这个综合差异
就是平均差异值大于了某个阈值的时候
我说不好意思
老哥你就是一个边界
而这个阈值是多少呢
他首先是把那个整个这个图片啊
转换到一个就是亮度空间
亮度空间的话呢就是个颜色空间的概念
就是说我们的看到图像是有颜色的
对不对
但是呢其实每个颜色对亮度是有个色感的
这里面就是在这边的话
就右边有个公式
就是那个你会发现
就是绿色的亮度贡献是最大的
蓝色亮度贡献是最小的
红色是居中的对吧
这个这个数值是非常了不起的经验数值
这个基本上你们所有的做这个
就是把这个比如说财大家在玩手机的时候
特别喜欢把这个彩色照片变成黑白照片
很有艺术感
对不对
那基本上你就用这个公式一算
你就可以迅速的把一个彩色照片变得
变成黑白照片好
我变成了黑白黑白照片之后
我对每个像素对它的上下左右几个邻居去找我
比较一下我们的色差
如果我们的色差综合色差超过这个阈值的时候
我就说不好意思
老哥
你就是我的一个边界点
你就有可能我需要对你进行NTA类型了
那这个时候呢他就拿到了每个点
比如说以这个为例子啊
我们这边取了一个很小的一块铜线
他就以那个高亮的绿色的点
他就说哎呀
我这个颜色变化到底是这个竖向的变化多呢
还是横向的变化多
因为我要是反走样的话
是不是我要和那个跟我差别很大的
那个这个像素进行这个blending
对不对
他其实呢用了一个非常聪明
而简单的这个一个卷积算法
就是诶他沿竖向转了卷了一下
加算了个绝对值
横向卷了一下
算了个绝对值
基本上就是一个9×9的矩阵啊
3×3的矩阵拍上去诶
它可以判断出来
好像比如以这个例子的话
我的横向好像这个差别大一点好
我的横向无非也就是左边和右边的邻居
对不对
他在这比较说诶
是我左边的邻居跟我这个差距大一点呢
还是我右边的邻居跟我差距大诶
他这边一看我的我的右边的邻居是一
我是零对吧
那我肯定是右边的领域上
他就得到了一个叫offset的朝向
意思就是说
我如果要进行ANTA类型反走样的blending的话
我应该跟他去
本来定
因为我们两个差距大
大概率是在这个地方会出问题的
对不对
这个方法是不是很简单
很直觉
好有意思的地方就来了
你有了这个blending的话
我不能够很粗暴的blending吧
这个是他想法特别巧妙的一个地方
就是说OK那我从我的这个点出发
我向上的那个那个就是我应该不在那个点
我们形成一个对
我们之间呢求个平均的这个强度值
然后呢我们就沿着这个
你刚才不是讲了一个方向吗
你一个朝上的方向
那我的perpendicular垂直的方向就是左右
对不对
我沿左边沿右边就一直找
找什么呢
找就是如果我找下去一对一对的像素
如果呢你的颜色变化跟我是差不多的好
我认为我们是一伙的
我们就不动
但是呢我一旦找到说诶你的两个相邻的pixel
它的颜色变化一下子发生了巨大的
这个就是跟我不一样
比如说你找到最这个最左边是两个白色的像素
它两个颜色是一致的对吧
好像跟我不一样
对不对
他找到最右边诶
发现两个都是黑的
它的颜色变化也跟我不一样
我等于什么呢
我找到了一个边的两个端点
唉这个地方是他最巧妙的地方
好这个时候它有意思的地方就来了
他呢就把我的左边这个端
右边这个端两个长度进行比较
唉这个比较就告诉我什么呢
就告诉说我是更应该去听我的
这个就是我自己一点呢
还是更应该听别人一点
但这个地方这个数学我就不展开了
其实它的基本的原理是什么呢
就是我们小时候学的那个相似三角形
三相似三角形的原理
因为这里面都是一个正的矩形吗
那你在里面做任何一条切线的话
你会发现啊
它的这个值你根据两边AG的长短长短的话
你就知道你在这个上下的这个距离是多少
大家想像三角形的原理对不对
所以他就用一个非常简单的原理
但是呢它就可以算出来
说我每一个点我去真实渲染
它采样的时候
我应该采样的时候往上移一点点
往下移一点
就是因为你想想看
我在绘制的时候
实际上我是一个差值
所以说我可以取一点我周边领域的颜色
这里面利用了就是我们的显卡的这个texture
sample领域的机制
我现在之前课程给大家讲解
text3里的核心是什么
Blinear interpolation
相当于说我只要把它坐标往上移
零点几个像素的话
实际上我就可以取我领域的颜色
3632非常巧妙
它巧妙的地方就在于是说
每一个点他只自己这么算
每个点自己找自己的H
但是呢当所有点算出来的时候
他就能出现右边这样一个结果
大家看右边那个结果是不是很帅对吧
所以其实啊我想这个算法
为什么我觉得他很很有意思啊
它基本上只用到了
我们大概呃初中的这个数学知识
真的是平面几何的知识
连立体几何的知识都没有用到
只是用最简单的颜色
然后呢比大小比边长长短
但是呢它没有让你多绘制任何一点东西
但是他就把一个基本上可以接受的效果
给你绘制出来
那这里面的话呢就有这样的一个结果
你看比如说像这个城堡对吧
它的右侧他这里面的几个图呢
第一个图就是那个黄色和蓝色的图
就代表他找到了方向
哎我到底是vertical的多一点
还是这个horizontal
就是还是还是数值的多啊
还是那个数值的多一点
然后呢
接下来几张图就表示说诶
我要去找到它那个颜色到底朝左朝右
朝上朝下对吧
还有呢接下来那个图的话表示说诶
我我应该根据我的找到了那个边对吧
我应该往我的邻居往哪个邻居去靠
然后最后它形成的结果
大家看一下那个结果是不是还是挺不错的
其实FXAA的话是一个非常实用的一个算法
而且包括其实现在现在现在显卡里面
基本上就直接集成了这个这个方法
效果也非常好
那么它的速度呢实际上是非常快的
我我们像我们就是一个商业级的游戏的话
很多时候大家也在用FXFXA
这就是一个非常好的一个思路
这就是我讲的
就是哎我一辈的什么都不都不去做额外的信息
信息
我只是对这个数据进行观察和处理
我也能对它进行这种反走样后处理
那么这是一种流派
那么第二种流派是什么呢
是ta但但这个我不展开去讲了
就是它的核心思想是什么呢
就是说其实你不就是要反走样嘛对吧
那有个简单的方法
就是说这个在这个世界啊
我对他渲染过去渲染了很多针
其实我在你过去的帧里面
我只要找到这个像素对应的时候
我把你的那个信号拿过来
跟我进行加权平均的时候
实际上也是完成了一个信息的blending
对不对
这个思想其实非常的重要
其实在我们很多现代引擎的算法里面
我们都用了这个就是叫temporal
就是时序上的数据
就是我这一帧我会利用前一帧的数据进行计算
那这里面就引入了一个很有意思的概念
我们叫做这个motion vector
就是说我当前像素看到的每一个点
他在上一帧的上映的时候
大家知道吗
它自己会动
对不对
然后呢它的这个这个这个相机也会动
那我们就找关系了
说哎我这边呢现在我脸上这个点
我在上一帧的时候
它的像像素的什么地方
那我如果动了之后
他的vector就会往这边走一走
这个地方
当然这个地方很很复杂了
它其实是在渲染那边
我要做这个准备
但是呢你有了这个东西之后
实际上你就可以和上一章进行这种blending
那么他这个ta的聪明在什么地方呢
就是说他也是不需要你去做更多的采样
但是的话呢我在时间轴上找数据
我也能进行我的anta lion的运算
那么就是这这是一个TA的一个效果了
就比如说这里面一个鼓
一个角色站在桥上
这个角色是在动的
你会发现就是说对于静态物体
但是这个时候相机是不动的
就是静态物体
它的motion vector几乎是黑的
就表示不同
但这个motion vector实际上是放大了很多倍了
那么对天上的云在动
包括那个角色在动的时候
它的motion vector就是有有就是有值的
但是我们对他的
因为它是有方向性的嘛
我们对它的PVE方向进行了RGB的CODEC
就是进行了编码
然后呢我们再去算他之前的布兰妮的权重
这个布兰妮的权重指的是什么呢
就是我当前这一章的执行度
和我过去的一针的执行度
你会发现这里面有个有意思的细节
这是我们在做的时候
我们经常会用的一个hack
就是说呃当这个物体在高速用运动的时候
我们会更加的相信当前这一帧的结果
然后呢不会过度相信过学生的结果
但是呢如果这个东西的话呢
就是它基本静止的话
那两边的权重是差不多的
所以的话呢你会发现这个权重
对于这个就是运动的东西的话
他当前的权重会略高一点
最后你形成的结果是这样的一个结果
所以ta的话呢
现在也是游戏引擎里面非常主流的一个
NTLS的一个算法
在这里给大家看一个就那个实践的结果
这个结果的话呢实际上它不是游戏了
它实际上是NVIDIA自己做的一个一个一个一个demo
从效果上来看其实还非常的好
大家能注意到就是比如像高光啊
像那个几何细节
当你的这个ta的没开的时候
它有很多的抖动
特别像那个吧台上的那种高光
大家能能不能看得到
但是我不知道直播推流的效果会怎么样
那这里面有一个细节啊
就是说有没有发现就ta1旦开了之后
它的像素和它没有开的时候有个小小的错位
这是为什么呢
因为你的相机一直在动对吧
但ta我老师要跟过去的那个图像进行blending
所以呢它会有一点点小的offset
这是我个人认为ta的一个问题
而且ta做不好的时候
有时候会出现一些残影
这也就是说你在时序上的比较的时候
出现的问题
所以啊ta FX a对吧
实际上是现在比较主流的
NTAS的这样的一个算法
讲到这儿
基本上我们的渲染从几何地形
天空语音fog天
还有这个就是说AMAINCLUSION对吧
ANTELINE基本上有了
讲到这
大家是不是觉得哎
我们的渲染是不是基本上已经ready了
但是呢事实上我们还有一个非常重要的一个part
没有上来
就是我们叫做后处理
其实这边我刚才本来放了一张图的
就是这个后处理啊
对于整个游戏渲染来讲
我个人一直认为是个美颜相机
就是所谓3A大作
你只要把他的后处理这一趴给关掉之后
你无论上什么高端的渲染
你看起来也就那么回事
但是呢你一旦上了这个滤镜
上了后处理之后哇
那简直是你一看就是大片感就出来了
我相信很多同学喜欢玩摄影啊
喜欢做这种图片梳理的人
都知道我这句话在讲什么
那么后处理对于游戏引擎渲染来讲的话呢
就是它的这个大滤镜对吧
就是美颜美颜相机
那好那后处理到底有哪几趴呢
今天呢我讲的就相对比较简单一点
就是说我讲几个就是最常用的就后处理啊
其实他无非也就是两个目的
第一个一一类
目的呢是为了它在物理上把它做正确
比如说我要让这个画面正确的被曝光
大家想想我们我们拍照的原理对吧
我们相机拍照整个真实世界的那个
就是那个它的光强和明暗变化
幅度是很大很大的
就是一个太阳光可能是一个烛光的几亿倍对吧
但是的话我拍到一张照片上的时候
诶我要进正确的曝光对吧
我才能产生我想要的效果
那么还有呢是什么呢
就是说哎我还有一些光晕的效果对吧
那么这都是这个我们叫做物理真实的需要
那还有一个是什么呢
就是哎我要有些风格化的表达对吧
这里面就是著名的这个就是color grading的效果
所以今天的话呢我只讲三个效果
就是这也是三个我认为是最常用的效果吧
第一个是blooming
第二个呢是这个同map就是曝光
第三个代码是color grading调色
你看就是先给你上光晕
美元的光晕
第二个呢我帮你给你曝光团队对吧
第三个呢我再给你整个画面调色
基本上一个漂亮的美女就这样可以产生了
我们先讲什么叫blue嘛
布鲁米
其实在那个游戏里面是非常常用的一个现象
就是你在游戏里面看到很多霓虹灯啊
强光晕啊
你是不是觉得光有点刺眼
那这个效果呢就是bloom effects
那么bloom effects的话呢
实际上在就是物理学
在我们的这个计算机的引擎里面或者渲染中
我们经常有一些讨论
就是这个到底什么原因
为什么我看了那个强光
我能看到旁边的一些光晕
那么这里面有很多种解释了
毕竟第一种解释就是
他觉得我们的人眼跟相机一样
相机大家知道有个光圈对吧
对于任何突破性的成像的话呢
实际上因为它并不是一个完美的小孔成像
它实际上并不能完美的聚焦到一个焦平面上
所以它就会产生一些这个散发发散
那发散的话呢
这个叫every disk这样的一个东西
你可以看到这样的一个disk
那么这是一种解释了
其实还有一种解释是什么
他认为我们人眼里面的晶状体里面是很多叫
还记得上节课我们讲的叫participant media
就是半透明材质诶
这种半透明的材
这个叫这种这种叫
就是这个里面有就有介质的材质吧
这个中文真的不知道怎么翻译
就是participating media
然后呢
他说这些partician media呢就跟气溶胶在里面一样的
就是它会产生这个miss gathering
大家还记得什么叫miss gerine吗
就是说那个光照过来之后
它会沿着光的方向
产生一个有迹象的这样的一个反射
对不对
那么好
当光射过来在我的眼睛里面
我眼睛里面很多小液珠啊
小液体在里面
它会产生一些反射
所以这些反射在我的这个视网膜上
形成这样光晕的效果
那不管它什么原理吧
但是这个效果是我们是真实能看得见的
对不对
包括我们可以看到就是有些那个照片啊
它实际上也能产生这样的一个不入门的效果
那么好
那怎么去做它呢
其实非常简单
就是诶我渲染出一个光照出来
对不对
那我首先呢把它高亮的地方给它取出来
高亮的地方怎么取呢
首先第一步我要把整个画面转成一个
我要算它的int luminous
就是它的亮度
大家还记得前面我们讲的那个亮度算法
对不对
就是ARGB3个颜色给个不同的权重
绿绿色高一点对吧
红色次之
蓝色最最低算出它的亮度
当它的亮度超过某个阈值的时候
我们就认为哦大哥你这个地方很亮
那么这个阈值呢说句实话是一个magic number对吧
那么最初的做法就是大于一
但实际上这个一呢在现代游戏渲染中
其实我们认为它也不一定正确
因为现在游戏渲染中
有的时候我们基本上都是HDR的那个光强的强度
幅度会非常的大
所以有的时候我们有的人会选择
这个平均的广场亮度啊
这种方法来算啊
这个我觉得会更好一点
那么他的就把所有这种
我们认为他的那个LUMINANCE
就是它的亮度超过我的阈值的区域
全部把它取出来了
但是呢记记住它取的是它的颜色
不仅仅是它的那个就是它的强度好
当我取出这个东西的时候
其实呢我们图形学的精神就来了
就是凡事不行
我就hack一下
我就给他B乐一下对吧
那我们就上一个大名鼎鼎的高斯不乐
那么高斯bl其实是非常简单的
比如说我们上一个5V5的
这个就是55的高斯bl
就是在二维空间做不了的话呢
实际上它高斯的方程
它有一个很巧妙的一个特性
就是说假设我做一个5×5的卷积的话
实际上它可以通过两次
就是五个像素的卷积就可以实现25-1
这个讲解来说有点细节了
但实际上你可以理解成就是说对于每一个点
我第一个pass把它上下的就是上下的这个五根相
其实是上下的两个相邻像素把它合到一起去好
我形成一个结果诶
我第二个pass的时候
还是每个点是那是上一个pass的结果啊
把它左右合到一起
你把这个最后合到一起
它的数学结果呢
就相当于你在每个点
把周边25个像素全部取了一遍的结果
这个呢实际上就会让你的
比如说我我假设我的高斯的卷积的课程都很大
比如说我是一个九个像素
就是这个九以九为半径的这样的啊
久为直径的这样的color的话
原来我要卷80一个数值
但是在这里面的话
我只需要卷19个数值
所以这样的话我的那个计算量就会小很多
所以呢我加个高兴的话
我时常就可以得到我的B入门的这个区域
那么哎但是呢这样不露出来的区域
不漏出来的区域呢其实是不够大的
大家想想看
如果能真的形成我们这种朦胧的效果的话
大家想想那个坑的有多大
可能要几十个
三四十个
四五十个
那大家想想
就算是我用这种快速的方法的话
我一个每一个像素点我要去卷上百个数据的话
这是不是很疯掉了
那聪明的这个人类就有个方法
就这也是一个非常经典的一个方法
就是我用一个pyramid的方法
就是说我对这个图像不断的进行
当三我在他最低的一节用一个color去
不乐的话
你想想看我对它进行这个不热的效果
经过一级级的放大回来的时候
是不是这个光晕就很大
所以他的做法其实非常简单
就是哎我在最低的一届
我对它进行高速bug
然后呢把它放大之后
跟原来的图再加到一起
但注意啊
这里面加的话是有个权重的
这就是一个图形学的一个黑科技了
就是你这个权重到底是
比如说原来的那个图是0.5
这个图是0.5
还是原来那个图0.3
你这个图是0.7
这个呢每一家都是自己设的
其实每一个引擎给的方法都不一样
甚至这个东西我可以开放给艺术家
然后呢就是说我每一层加回来
再对它进行一次不乐
然后再把它放大
再跟上一集合到一起
加全合到一起再放大
最后你能得到一个这个光晕的很开的结果
但是你的计算量的话呢
它是远远小于你在那个最高精度的图上
进行一个大的放大
其实这个思想啊其实在渲染中非常常见
就是我我我们在后面做很多预算的时候
实际上我们经常讲叫half resolution
或者说我用这个MIMP的方法
一层层从从低往上算
都是降低我的计算的复杂度的一个方法
那么你最后得到了这个bug的这个
这个这个这个就是bloom的效果图的话
你把它叠加到你原始的图上的话
你就能得到一个非常漂亮的一个blue的效果
所以这就是一个啊非常简单
但是呢又非常重要的效果
因为在现在游戏中你可以看到
就比如像这个里面
如果你把bloom效果关掉的话
那么你看到的这个场景的艺术感
就会小很多对吧
那么所以说这是一个非常基础的一个
后处理的效果
那么另外一个后处理效果是什么呢
就是我们叫做tm mapping
那么这个通病呢听上去这个很陌生啊
那么它其实解决的问题是什么呢
其实在我们相机中的时候
经常用的
就是说大家知道
就是比如说你们有没有这样一个经验
你如果啊去大家如果有去过教堂或者是大礼堂
大礼堂的话呢
白天窗子那边会非常的亮对吧
你进去之后你会发现诶
你看的是窗子也看得清楚
然后里面的东西也看得非常清楚
对不对
但是这时候你如果掏出一个手机
拍个照片的时候
你大概率拍出来的是
要么就是里面的东西看得很清楚
窗子那边已经爆掉了对吧
要么就是窗子那边看得很清楚
里面看起来特别的黑
这是为什么呢
因为整个真实世界的光照
它的range是非常大的
你的曝光如果没有仔细调过的话
你就会出现就是说那个就是要么就是明亮
不就是过暗啊
过量要么就是暗部过暗
就这个效果
那所有搞photograph
搞照片的同学应该都知道我在讲什么
我记得我以前在那个就是国外
我看那些那个卖房子的人
拍那个房子的那个照片的时候
像国内也是一样的
就是他他们拍出来的照片
比我自己拍我家的照片看起来完全就不一样
为什么他拍的时候外面是蓝天白云
家里面窗明几净
实际上这个呢是要认真的拍过的
反正这个技术的话
我当时是不会的
对吧好
但是我如果做渲染
我知道怎么做
因为我知道我要做tom mapping
那么通拍品它的基本的解决的问题是什么呢
就是说其实现在我们游戏的渲染
基本上都是HDR的渲染
就是说光阳光能直射到的地方的话
它的亮度可能是非常非常高对吧
但是在阴影里面它的亮度可能是非常的低
那么就是说你如果不用一条曝光曲线
就是说把这个这么大range的这个这个光照数据
把它映射到一个
就是啊LDR或者SDR的映射数据的话
实际上你看到的东西
就是就像我们的左边那张图一样
就是天空它已经过爆掉了
然后呢下面的环境你看上去他已经看不清楚了
而且出现了色偏
因为这个就是说如果你因为颜色
如果它的亮度很高
但是呢你做了个clamp
就是说超过一的我给你截断的话
其实这种HTR的颜色它会产生一个色偏的
那么我们需要用通过通mapping把他曝光对
那你看通过这个这里面用了一个film filmic cube
就是说一个fm curve
待会讲就是说哎他曝光完之后
你会发现这边的天空也看得清楚了
这些房子的颜色也是对的
那么这个里面的话呢
它的算法其实是非常简单的
也就是说我把你一个0~40
0~50的值
我通过一条曲线映射回一个0~1之间的值
就是这么一个简单的想法
那么那么你想这个映射的话
在二维空间上是不是就是一条曲线对吧
那这里面的话呢
就是说同8P其实有很多方法了
很多曲线
但是呢其实你会发现
行业随着现在这么多年的发展
其实最经典的曲线也就这么几条
那这里面首先我要讲解一下大名鼎鼎的FILMIC的
这个就是那个这条曲线
这条曲线的话呢首先从名字上取下来
就非常的霸气
为什么当年我为什么觉得这个曲线
我一定要用呢
就是因为它的名字太吊了
它让你的游戏产生出了像电影般的画质感
这个好像如果没记错的话
应该是ni dog他们自己提出来的
然后整个行业都觉得非常的棒
那么他很聪明的一件事情是什么呢
就是说这样一条曲线
大家想想看
我去曝光
我怎么去曝光啊
我我去算
就是我我有任何一个算出来一个点的
这个它的luminous就是它的光的强度
我去算它新的映射的时候
我是把这个东西变成一张纹理
我对它进行采样
但这个好像效率很低对吧
而且这个怎么存呢
存存是可以确实可以存
但是呢这也是他们很厉害的地方
就是他们其实是用一个多项式的公式的拟合
拟合出来的这样的一个通mapping
就支持他的shader code
但这color大家有有有兴趣的话
可以仔细研究一下
这个就非常像我刚才讲的那个做AO的时候
那个老哥
他从这个一个简单的AO数值就可以推出来
你的multi scaring数值
一个道理
它就是一个你讲不清楚它为什么work了
但是它它就是work了这么一个数值
它给你产生了这样一条curve
但这条curve产生的效果它就是非常的好
那么这个呢
我认为是我们游戏行业的巅峰水平了对吧
FILMIC的这个东西
我记得我在10年前
我在读那个他的paper的时候
我就觉得惊为天人
我说啊敢叫FILMIC的
叫曲线
那一定是跟电影行业是高度相关和一致的
我怀疑当时nt dog的这个technical artist
是对着电影胶片去调的
就是说能调出这样的一个效果
但是这个呢世界上的事情就是不怕不识货
就怕货比货
那现在在我们行业里面呢
大家慢慢慢慢的在切的
我们叫做ACES
大家看到这个ACS的logo是不是有点熟
中间那个东西是什么
是小金人
对不对对
那就是那个美国电影协会
这个就是他是个academy
哇
这个名字听academy的意思就是学院
电影学院就是电影界的同志们说
哎你们这些人都在瞎搞
你们根本不懂什么叫颜色
什么叫这个这个调色的这个真谛
所以ACES它结合他多年的经验
提出了他的一套就是这个曝光曲
就ACES这条曲线
实话实说啊
这套曲线我觉得效果确实做得是非常不错的
确实是这帮大事
而且他解决了一个非常厉害的东西是什么呢
就是说实际上在我们的颜色
就是我们渲染出来的东西的时候
它实际上会在不同的设备上去去去播放
比如说现在大家买显示器的时候
你们会有两种显示器选择
一种是HDR的显示器
对不对
一种是普通的非HDR显示器
那么你最后这个颜色怎么映射上去
这个还是那个一点
其实还有一点更讲究的是什么呢
就大家看我们人眼的颜色的感感知都是相对的
比如说同样一个绿色
你在一个比如说我在打印的一张纸上
或者在我们电脑屏幕上周围都是白光的情况下
你那个绿色感知到同样的RGB啊
和你在电影院里面周围都是黑色的
你我要让你感知到一样的绿色
其实它两个颜色是要调过的
而ACES的这个color的这个同mapping的话呢
他给你转换完之后
你后面再加一道工序的话
你就能够无差别地适应到各种各样的现实终端
这一点确实我觉得就是说啊
他们的这所有的数值
所有的曲线都是有大量的专业的
这个就是视觉的艺术家去调校过的
所以这个的话呢就是目前我们可以看到
就是在工业界里面越来越多的人
我们在用ACES的这个模型
所以我觉得这个真的是我们这个行业
一个打脸的一个一个很有意思的一个故事
就是说我们本来觉得我们已经尽了全力了
我们自称我们可以达到电影般的效果了
结果人家正主跑过来说
我来教你怎么做颜色
怎么做这个这个这个就是说曝光的这个曲线
那实话实说的话呢
这这张图是从那个知乎上的
那个就是那个叛逆者敏敏
他那个博客上我拔下来的
那么他这个工作做的非常的好
就是说你可以看到同样一个场景
其实你用各种不同的语言去曝光呃
我个人觉得就是说那个就是ACES的
这条曲线的话
确实效果很漂亮
它的亮部看起来足够暗
足够足够亮
然后呢色彩足够饱满
然后呢暗部的话呢其实看着也很清晰
整个画面的话显得明暗非常有致对吧
其实我们人眼的话天然的对这种就是高对比的
这种就是非常vivid生动的东西是感兴趣的
所以这也是就是说目前在游戏行业里面
大家越来越多的去签到
这个ACESS这条曲线的一个原因
那么所以说这就是我们的那个我们的post processing
第2part就这个都这part非常重要
因为现在大家做引擎的话呢
一般你的太阳光的亮度基本上是HDR了
你宣传的东西HDR
所以你的场景美不美
同花瓶非常重要
那么刚才讲的这个blooming啊
TOMAP啊
基本上还是一个比较符合真实的实践的东西
接下来讲的这一趴的话呢
那就是彻头彻尾的美颜相机了对吧
大家看这张图对吧
左边和右边它的区别是什么
其实是同个照片
但是我们调了个色之后
你会发现感觉完全不一样了
对不对
那么右边的这张图一下子让你有这种诶
有这种老照片新闻感
有种年代感
有情绪感的
对不对
其实color grading
我认为是现代游戏中非常非常重要的一个东西
但是它呢它简单到让你觉得都不可以想象
那么其实在这个它其实在现代游戏中
我去表达情绪
表达环境
比如说你打boss对吧
你这个boss特别难打
然后呢你的情绪非常低的时候
你会发现整个游戏画面的颜色
好像色相在偷偷摸摸地发生变化
其实这就是这个color grading在在起作用
color grading呢又有一个有一个叫法叫LUT叫root
Look up table
他什么意思呢
就是说其实它本质上是什么呢
就是说你原始的一个颜色和我想调到的一个
色相空间的一个映射
这个映射呢我们一般用一个表格来做
这个表格长什么样子呢
其实大家可以想象到
就是如果我在世界上所有的颜色不是RGB吗
256256256吗
它不就是一张3D的texture嘛
对不对
那好那任何一个就是你给我的颜色
我呢把它变化成另外一种颜色
所以这就是个映射嘛对吧
那么好
那如果这个3D texture的话呢
在我们早期的时候
因为早期很多硬件它不支持3D texture诶
我可以把它拍平成一个二维的texture对吧
我一样可以存到SHADER里面
那么这里面的话有一个小细节
就是说其实啊我们并不需要存一个
256×256乘256
这么大的材质
这个材质还是蛮大的
实际上呢很多时候在工业界里面
大家用的发现A1616乘16
或者32乘三十二十三
32基本够用了
这是为什么呢
因为颜色它是连续的
所以你大概觉得颜色怎么变化就好了
那你在中间的那个颜色
比如说啊我们假设只采32×32对吧
那你现在假设告诉我说诶我现在的颜色值是
比如说啊75啊
这个值有点难吧
我讲解简单一点
比如说啊69好吧
那我颜色值的话呢
我32~250个隔了八个
对不对
那好我下一个是64对吧
那其实它就在64和72之间差一个值
其实那个值基本上就够用了
这就是为什么所有的look up table的话
就是color gradient
Look up table
它一般不会做得非常的密度
这就够了
那么这个东西的话呢非常的简单
对不对
但是呢其实非常的实用
因为它的好处是什么呢
你这是一个典型的就是程序员写完一个算法
接下来所有的事情交给艺术家自由游戏发挥的
比如说在PHOTOSHOP里面
你艺术家可以做一张原始图
比如说我们经常干的事情是什么
游戏以及截张图
然后艺术家呢在上面加一个图层
自己调调调
调出各种各样想要的效果
然后PHOTOSHOP一个插件说我要导成look那个color gradient
Look up table
然后你可以选择我要导成2D的还是3D的
哐叽一键啪
这个图学生成了艺术家
不用管这个图是怎么算的
但是呢你把这个look up table
读到我们的color grading的后后处理的话
你真的能在游戏里面产生一模一样的效果
那么甚至像这边那个这个软件的话呢
它是专门做这个color grading
look look up table的一个软件
那这里面的话artist的话
他就不用那个就自己去P图了
它在里面拉一拉颜色
像空间的分布诶
它就能完成这样的一个变化
所以这个东西的话呢
实际上是我自己在工程经验中
我认为artist是特别喜欢的东西
而且呢做游戏引擎的话
我认为这是你必须要做的东西
所以其实怎么去解释这个color grading呢
其实啊color grading这个东西的话
我认为是啊在游戏渲染里面
性价比最高的一个功能
非常简单
但是呢对游戏的效果我认为是有质的飞跃的
它原始图你看着就很一般蓝天白云那个东西
但是他一旦color a上去之后
你就觉得非常的压抑
非常的有情绪对吧
所以color grading是post process的话呢
我们非常重要的一个part好
讲到这儿的话呢
这是我们的渲染的这个核心算法
基本上就讲完了
好
这个时候呢
我们就开始到我们这课程的后面的这个
这个收官的阶段了
大家回顾一下我们rendering的四节课
其实最开始从哪个东西开始的对吧
是从我们卡基亚老先生的这个
render equation开始的
这个我今天的课讲了这么长时间
讲了将近有七八个小时了
但是呢所有的东西都在他老学生的方程里面
真的这个我实话实说
我没有做
我们图形学
到目前为止
还没有超越老学生的这个方程的东西在里面
但是老先生的方程给出来之后
我们就死去活来
大家回想一下是不是已经有点忘了
比如说第一节课里面
我们教给大家说哦
这个世界你是用这个mesh材质对吧
去那个SHADER去绘制出来
然后你要做卡里
你要把不必要的东西裁剪掉
这样你这个世界就能画的出来了
对不对
第一节课讲的还可以比较简单好
到第二节课我们开始讲的就比较难了
就告诉大家说
其实呢卡基尔形式的方程最难的是什么
比如像shadow对吧
包括像那个GLOBINATION
它的全局光照
就光和这个世界是怎么变化的
好光和材质呢有就是我们最难的这个材质系统
所幸现在有PB2材质一统天下
那让我们一下子
这个材质基本上完成了一样的统一
这是我们第二节课的内容
大家知道了哦
我怎么能画一个很有观感
很有真实感的这样一个世界
那么第三节课呢我们学到了哦
那这个世界里面比较难以表达的
是个巨大的地形对吧
复杂的天空和云
我们有一系列的这个非常复杂的这种
积分算法诶
我们能够近似模拟卡基亚老学生的需求
同时能把这个世界做的非常大
开放世界有无数的细节好
那今天我们这节课呢
看起来学的是一些零零碎碎的东西对吧
比如说我们知道了
如果表达这个世界
我们一定要有NB的CLUSION对吧
这样我们这个世界才有感觉凹凸有致
然后呢我一定要有一层fog
让这个世界更有层次感对吧
而且呢因为世界里的东西太多了
我的屏幕reduction又不够
所以呢我们一定要anta lien
让这个世界变得诶看起来更平滑
那最后呢我们还要做一些后处理给它进行美颜
所以我们需要把这个bloom的效果
光晕的效果把它表达出来
我们要对它进行正确的曝光
不要让这相片看起来曝光还有色偏对吧
最后呢哎我们可以上一个魔法科技color grading
把这个整个游戏的画面调成我想要的这种色相
有了这么多东西之后
我们是不是真的就知道这个游戏
这个产品是怎么绘制了
实际上呢这里面有个很重要的东西
叫做rendering pipeline
也就是最简单的解释是什么呢
我叫做绘制顺序也好吧
就是说实际上这么多的算法
它必须有一套规则
谁先做谁后做对吧
然后呢
这样的话呢我才能保证这个东西是有序的
这就是我在第一节课给大家讲的
就是说其实游戏引擎
你的渲染和图形学里的渲染最本质的区别是
我们是没有办法抽象出一个简单干净的算法
实际上我们在一个游戏画面里面
真的是几十种到上百种的算法同时在运作
然后呢我们要让它的效果是不出问题的
那这里面的话呢我们就需要有一个pipeline
就是把这么多的算法依次依次往里面放
那么最简单的排放是什么呢
就是哎我先把shadow map算出来对吧
把光影明暗算出来
接下来呢我把物体依次放进去
对它进行光照进行shading对吧
每个光晕我给它做一次
然后最后诶我把这个灯最后的结果再放呢
post process对它进行一个
比如说blue效果算不算对它进行一个曝光
进行一个color grading
那就能拿到我想要的结果
这其实就是一个最简单的排版
大家别小看它这个pipeline的话
事实上是真的可以work的
很多商业级的游戏就是这么做出来的
那这个pipeline的话呢
就是大名鼎鼎的叫我们叫做FORENDERING对吧
就是说我对每一个mesh
对每个光我把它炫一遍
就像我们这边用小引擎做个例子
大家看他就说诶你东西一个一个的被绘制出来
对吧
然后好for the rendering的话呢
这里面你们看到所有的东西啊
注意在这里每一个细节就是A
为什么天空是最后绘制
因为天空第一个是最远
第二个呢这是我们下一页讲的东西
就是说PHOENN有个小细节是什么呢
就是说我们有一些物体啊
它是透明物
透明物的绘制啊
它首先不能够和不透明物质和物体
混合到一起去
他必须是最后回绘制
而且透明物质物体绘制呢
它有一个细节叫什么呢
叫transparency sorting
就透明物排序
为什么呢
就是说当我在屏幕上去叠加透明效果的时候
如果你的不透明材质在前面的话
挡着我的话
那我这透明我是不是不需要会了
对不对
我说我z buffer我就知道了
那如果我的透明物在你前面的话
那我事实上要混合你射出来的光
对不对
那实际上我必须要在你之后好
那是这是透明物和不透明物之间的关系
所以为什么
透明物一定要在不透明的物体之后之后去绘制
那么但是呢如果我这时候有两个三个
四个五个六个透明物
我怎么去绘制呢
这里面就有一个很著名的一个算法
叫TRANSPARENSIN
就是说把所有的透明物由远极近的绘制
就是说我首先绘制离相机远的
然后依次往相机镜的绘制
这是为什么
大家想想看
当玻璃两个玻璃我前后重叠的时候
我是不是先要后面的东西颜色先出来之后
我前面的玻璃罩上去
我才能够把你的颜色做
对对吧
所以这边有一个例子
就是说一个黄色的
一个绿色的玻璃和一个红色的玻璃
它两种不同方式叠叠在一起的话
它是产生的结果是不一样的
所以其实在现代的游戏引擎里面
就是transporting是一个非常难的问题
它其实会导致很多的bug
那么其实呢这个方法呢
差不多是在呃游戏引擎很早期大家就提出来了
但是呢事实上它是有问题的
比如说我上次在这个上面出现了一个概念
就是这三根棍子
它是三个透明物
那么你说哪个先哪个先哪个后呢
你会发现它是一个有点像莫比乌斯环
有点像一个puzzle一样
就是你无论怎么解释
他都解不了的
所以这种情况在我们游戏引擎里面怎么办
我们不管了对吧
我们一般用透明物的中心点去排序
所以你会发现就是在游戏中啊
透明物其实非常多
举个例子吧
比如说你扔下一颗手雷
怕一瞬间它炸出了很多的烟对吧
那个烟呢就是一个个的particle
它都是透明的
那个烟的排序
就这一件事情就让我们的游戏引擎难了好多年
我在下这个后面讲那个粒子系统的时候
会跟大家去讲一下
那个里面排序所遇到的各种困难
所以呢大家只要记住
就是说在forward rendering的时候
你一定要把透明物放在不透明的物体之后绘制
然后呢对它进行一次排序就好了
所以这样的一个pipeline呢
基本上就能完成早期的游戏的绘制过程
那么大家可以看到就是早期的像just cos对吧
像那个heavy rain
Heavin
其实是一个我很喜欢的游戏了
你看看它的效果做的其实还挺不错的
而且这是个正儿八经的3A游戏啊
还真的是卖钱了
但是呢这个技术的大概在十几年前吧
逐渐的这个pipeline被大家就觉得他有问题
那现在的话呢大家最主流的PAPI为什么要变呢
其实有一个很核心的问题
就是说在我们现代的游戏场景里面
它的光啊是非常丰富和复杂的对吧
你墙上吊的那个吊灯对不对
你扔出去的一个照明弹对吧
地上那个燃起的火把
所以说其实以一个现代游戏来讲的话
你的光是极其的丰富
所以这个时候呢
我们就引入了大名鼎鼎的叫延迟渲染
其实这个different shading
或者叫different rendering
那么different rendering呢
他的思想其实非常的简单
他说呢你不就是要渲染吗
我先把所有的物体我渲染一遍
但是呢我先不去算它和光的关系
光我放到后面去
我算什么呢
我把你的这个材质
比如说你的ABELE
你的SPECOLOR
你的roughness对吧
你的depth
全部扔到一个巨大的这个buffer里面去
这个buffer一般我们叫做g buffer
然后当我有了这个信息的时候
那我一块一块的光apply到这个屏幕上的时候
是不是我就可以只算光的部分了
这样的话我所有的顶点啊
所有的像素就不会被overdraw
每一个就是他最后的shading预算
只会去算最后一次
所以呢differ rendering
实际上是在过去的这个时间里面的话
大家在游戏引擎行业最常用的一种绘制
绘制方式
这个方式还有一个潜在的一个好处是什么呢
就是说大家讲到我们的材质
是不是越来越统一了
对不对
我们用了P2这个材质对吧
那其实早在PB2流行之前的话
人们已经开始逐渐喜欢
就是说把材质数据全部拍到我们的FM
这个g buffer里面去
这样让后面的计算的话高度的一致
这就是difficult rendering
这样的好处
就是它能够绘制很多光晕的这样的一个结果
那么就是different rendering的话呢
它的好处就是说它可以对光的处理
是非常的方便
就像我们比如说我们以前在做这个叫screen space light
就是我在screen
就是在那个屏幕上我要加很多小的点光的时候
诶
我只需要在点光要覆盖的那个区域
画一个小的disc
那个区域的话
我把那个光叠加上去
我以前还做过这screen
就这样这边这个结果可以花很多的小的点光
这个要表达这是晚上的街道的场景
是不是特别的有用对吧
那么而且呢它的那个就是渲染是很很容易debug
很多问题很容易发现
但是他的问题是什么呢
就是他的g buffer实际上是非常的废的
就是说我们讲的就是说在在硬件上
实际上我去读写这些数据
其实效率是非常低的
而这个问题呢在移动端的时候哦
这边我们先给大家看一个简单的视频
就是这个
这也是我们这一个星期
那个就是PO的引擎的一个更新
就是我们把differ rendering加上去了
大家可以看到
就是说我们会先生成它的G8er
然后呢再开始这个就是后面去渲染它
确定它
我每次看弹幕
同学们都让我多喝水
所以今天我就放了一瓶水放在这了啊
对响应大家号召
我就好好喝水
省得嗓子哑了
好哎呀
今天又讲了一个半小时
后面我争取两小时内能解决吧
好那么确实今天是最后一节课
我确定我必须要把所有的东西给大家先讲完
好
那么其实呢
这个时候就出现了著名的这个TALIRENDERING
TALIRENDERING的话呢
它的源头是什么呢
源头实际上是在移动端
因为移动端它有一个问题
就是说它对发热是特别敏感的
那么在移动端的话呢
什么东西是最容易发热呢
就是存储芯片
那么所以呢他做了这样一个结构
就是说在主板上它一个d run
d run上的话呢
它的速度比较慢
而且呢你在这读写的话是很消耗很多能量
但是它chips里面呢他又做了个s ros one的话呢
视频率特别高
但是它尺寸特别特别的小
那这时候他就想了
那这样吧
你不就要绘制画面吗
那我就在java层面把你的画面切成一小块一小块
你就一小块一小块
只渲染那一小块
你的几何那一小块的东西
然后呢哎我渲染好了之后
我把那一小块把它放到我们的free buffer里面
最终的结果
而不用存一个巨大无比的奇buffer
所以到今天就是现在
可能有一些越来越多的手游
开始用different renderings
其实在很早以前呃
呃英布就是其实现在主流
我猜那个手机上的渲染还是用FRENDERING制作
渲染
也是这个道理
那这个时候呢其实大家会发现
就是说怎样减少对这个frame buffer的读写的压力
其实我可以把画面拆成一小块一小块来
这样做效率更好
那么这样的一个差呢
实际上带来了一个额外的好处是什么呢
就是光可以被切割
就是会被卡到一个个的太阳里面去
也就是说在屏幕上的每一个小太阳
我上次知道的时候
我是被几个光给照照上的
那么实际上在每个tag
我只要做一个非常简单的view frustr的处理
我就知道说哎我这个tile里面到底有几个光
可见它们叫什么
叫light list
这个算法其实非常的简单
那么好
这个算法够不够
我们还可以再往后走一步
实际上呢我们在渲染这个世界的时候
我们在做设定的时候
我先不是会生成一个大的early或者叫PZ
我会生成它一个z buffer的深度
那实际上在每个tell
我事实上是可以知道他最远的和最近的
自己在那里
就像那个我们的右边途中
你这辆摩托车
它其实它的BACKFACE你是不会被设定的对吧
它只有它的front face a
它形成了一个小的区域
那我假设有一个点光源
点光源一般在空间中是一个球吗
其实我们就可以知道说哪几个tell会把它照到
哪些tell all
虽然空间上有
但是它不会被照到
你看这边就是说
其实那个点光源能覆盖到的只有几个tile
而大百分之就是可以说是90%以上
就是学生五以上的面积都不需要被他照到
这就是这个你对空间划分之后
带来了一个很大的优势
而这个TALIST那个rendering或者TBRENDERING的话
现在是很多游戏的主流的绘制方案
就是因为它对光的处理非常的高效
那么其实我们可以看到就是在5年前左右吧
很多的大作基本上是采取了这样的一个架构
你会发现在这里面的光影
各方面是那个处理得非常的好好
那基于这个town的话
这个pipeline的话
我们能不能再往前走一步呢
哎这个哦顺便给大家顺便穿插一个概念
叫forward的家
其实真的学图形学的话
你可能要背很多黑化的这个forward的家
在实际上没有那么夸张
就是刚才我讲的就是你是ford rendering
但是呢你按照一个tile excel绘制的话
我们叫做forward
加这个的话呢
实际上就是说啊对东端特别友好
其实即使在一些PC游戏上的话
也有人用这种方法去做好
那么还有如果我们对这个世界分成
就是在在那个像素空间
对它进行一个切分的时候
实际上刚才在那个Z的那个地方呢
我们不是算了z miz max吗
那其实有个更简单的方法是
我们对Z空间直接进行一个切分
好不好
我们就把这个空间分成一个个的那种
四棱锥的那个体柱
它叫class对吧
就是这种class base rendering的话
他就更加丧心病狂
你像这个case里面
我这里面应该有上千个光源吧
那实际上它就能够高效地做成return render
大家想象一下
如果还是用古老的这个forward rendering的话
那你这个几千光源
对这个场景几乎是没有办法渲染的
而这个classmates rendering的话呢
现在也在慢慢的变成
就是很多游戏引擎用的方法
但这个方法
它其实我觉得个人觉得没有什么太多的花头
它实际上就是你不需要再算什么zz m z max了
我就是一个tie
1tie去算这个对于light的这个visibility
那么最后呢我给大家讲一个
就是现在在蓬勃发展的一个新的rendering
pipeline的技术叫做visibility buffer
刚才我们讲的所有的这个渲染呢
大部分人用的都是FARENDERING
它本质上是什么呢
他把所有的材质信息
写到了一个巨大的G8缝里面去了对吧
这G8份里面我会存它的深度
存它的法向
存它的那个颜色
存它的这个那个模
那个粗糙度roughness
那么其实随着现代硬件的发展
大家意识到一件事情
就是说
我们其实可以把几何信息和材质信息剥离开来
我在一个frame buffer里面
我写什么呢
我写你这个像素它是属于哪一个几何体
就是你的primitive id
就比如说你是属于哪个啊
比如说我们之前讲的那个MSI
你属于哪个MASALT
然后呢你的这个你是你是你的传统id是什么
我就知道你的传统id
我还告诉你说你的这个传统里面你的那个点
他的那个就是叫biocentric corner
就是你在那个三角形的
因为就是大家如果学过图形学基本概念
就知道就是说一个三角形
我一个about central color叫叫什么重心坐标
我就可以知道你真正的是哪个点
我就知道从这三个点的数据提示好吧
那这样的话我有了primitive id
我有了BSA的话
实际上我可以反向的去查你这个物体系
你这个三角形应该用的是什么材质
你应该是什么
Normal
应该是什么东西
对不对
所以我其实用一个visibility
Visibility buffer
我把它几何信息全部存下来了
那么好
我有这样的一个信息之后
诶
我在后面可以对他直接的进行shading
那为什么这件事情这么重要呢
因为大家啊去去想一下
就是说其实啊在过去的计算机里面
我们一直认为材质呢渲染是比较复杂的
几何是比较简单的对吧
那么几何一般就是一个个的面片
但是在现代引擎
特别你当然看了像虚幻五的NANA这个技术对吧
包括像这个地平线最新的一座
它的那个foliage
其实它的几何密度是非常非常高的
很多时候它的几何会超过像素
那么传统的去写这个g buffer的方法的话
其实你会浪费掉大量的这种几何的overdraw
这个东西
然后呢我要去取大量texture fashion
大量的运算
所以呢其实大家在这个时候会发现说诶
我只需要把几何写上去就可以了
那么这个呢实际上在现代的很多引擎中
逐渐的逐渐的它成为一个非常重要的
rendering pipeline的一个发展方向
而且这里面还有一个原因
就是说我们现在的这个比如说GOMETERSHADER
mash shader越来越成熟
大家会发现一件事情
就是说我走传统的
就是诶我把顶点vertex index buffer传进去
然后呢rust riser去把它变成光栅化
然后再进行pixel shading
它的效率其实没有
我们自己直接去写它的光栅化的效率高
这个事情很神奇啊
你自己用GPU直接去写那个shader code
去把一个三角形rust rise成一个点
其实它的效率啊比硬件做的更快
那么还有一点是什么呢
就是说在g buffer里面的话
我在做设定的时候
我要不停的去查那个g buffer对吧
那那是一个texture sampling
其实那个texture sampling的效率是非常非常低的
但是的话呢我现在在那个visibility buffer里面
我在做设定的时候
实际上是我取到你的值之后
我直接是什么呢
我去查你的vb和IB那个效率其实是非常高的
所以的话呢vb的buffer
实际上是现代pipeline的话呢
一个很重要的一个前沿的发展方向
我们可以看到
就在我们可以预测在未来的三到5年的话
会有越来越多的这个管线
它会引引入这个机制
但是呢就是现在我看到的东西的话
它一般不会完全的不像低分的differ的设定
就是完全的是一个主主pine
现在它变成一个就是我
我的感觉像个增强型的pipeline
但是未来保不齐
随着技术的成熟的话
它变成一个主PAPI
这个方向的话
我觉得同学们可以关注
如果大家真的理解了什么叫differ rendering
理解了g buffer的话呢
你把这个东西反过来再理解一下去
你在那g buffer里面
differ shine存的是材质的全属性对吧
你想想的那一张贴图诶
在visit buffer里面
我存的是几何的全属性
那么你通过几何的属性呢
你也可以反向的找到材质
而且他用了VCD buffer
还有个好处
就是说我把所有的没有用的材质
信息全部剔除掉了
就是没有用的材质我都不需要
我只需要用我自己的药的材质
而且他的支持的材质类型会更加的复杂
更加的丰富
相反就是说你用g buffer的话呢
一般来讲它的材质是假设是一致的
好这个地方讲的有点多了
但是呢我觉得这是个很有趣的一个方向
大家可以关注好
那么懂了这些所有的东西
对不对
我们是不是就真的知道怎么做游戏了
那老套路还是比较难
那这里面的话呢
这是大名鼎鼎的unreal的这个
这个pipeline的图
大家看一看
这已经是画的
这是我见过画的最清晰最明了
但其实呢也是做了大量简化的一点PON的图了
大家看看有多复杂对吧
很多很多东西
但是的话呢就是说真的
我们去构建一个游戏引擎的时候
那这个地方就是大家会吓着大家了
就是构建引擎看听起来很难
对不对
但实际上的话呢
它每一个算法拆下来都都是可以理解的
都是可以读的
但是你真的贡献一个引擎的时候
其实他的就这么多算法在一起怎么work
实际上呢是非常麻烦的
它麻烦在什么地方呢
我觉得就麻烦在这么几个地方
第一个就是说我做完一个引擎对吧
我要给别人做各种各样的游戏
其实每个游戏的渲染需求都是不一样的
对不对
比如说这个人我希望我的NTLEEN用的是TA
那个人我喜欢用的是FXA
因为我要更强调我的效率对吧
那么好
那么但是呢我有那么多的模块
这些模块其实是什么呢
它是lego piece
是一个积木
这金木我怎么样自由的那个搭了起来
那么第二点是什么呢
就是每一个算法它除了计算之外
还要占用很多的就是存储资源
那么这个存储资源的话呢
比如说这个buffer那个buffer对吧
实际上在整个这一站渲染里面
它并不需要从头到尾
可能一个计算算完之后
他把结果存出来之后
给另外一个计算消耗掉之后
哎这个办法就应该被释放掉
但是呢如果你不去对它进行一个
进行一个精密的管理的话
其实你会发现很多的内存空间
很多的那个buffer
很多text空间
很多的显存空间全部是被浪费的
那么你如果一开始
当这个PON比较简单的时候啊
那还是有很多牛人管理的很好
他说哎我这地方重用那个调释放对吧
但是的话呢当PIPA变得非常非常复杂的时候
其实几乎没有人能管得了这件事情
那么第三个呢很大的挑战是什么呢
是随着这个DX12和van
这一代的这个graphics API的兴起
这一代graphics API
它最大的一个设计理念是什么呢
就是说我不再像早期的open gl或者DX9DX11样
就是把很多硬件的复杂度全给你封装起来对吧
对你来讲就是我上面的一个光
我设置一个材质参数
我设置个SHADER
Px shader
Word shader
我设置VBIBH动我就画出来
但是呢在van和direct12里面
它是几乎把这个裸的硬件的这个算力
给你开放出来了
包括它的内存
你怎么去管理对吧
你怎么去理解这个内存
你到底这个内存是啊是一个texture还是一个array
这个内存是可读可写
还是现在我要把它屏蔽起来
比如说最最重要的就是说因为我们的这个GPU啊
它是高度并行化的计算
很多的内存它是要加锁的
我们叫做memory barrier
我们加很多锁
这个锁你一旦没加
加对或者少加的话
他要么就是导致整个游戏直接就Rush掉了
而且在某些特殊情况会Rush掉
你都不知道
还有是什么呢
还有就是说哎
他会突然的就是进入了一个一个死循环对吧
我们叫死锁
死锁是写多线程最怕的一个东西
那么好
那这样的一个东西的话呢
实际上在现代真实的游戏引擎开发的时候
困难其实是非常非常大
那这个东西我们怎么去解决它
所以呢这里面的话呢
我今天就给大家只点一个概念
就是说叫render graph graph或者叫phone graph
这个概念的话
大家如果在那个就是如果大家玩引擎
比如说无论玩最新的那个一代的unreal
还是unity的话
大家看到就SRP对吧
就是script to render pipel
其实就是一个概念
就是说诶我们把这个pipeline里的所有的东西
把它变成一个的module
这个module的话呢
我一或者用脚本
甚至将来可以用可可拖拽的一个图
把这个pipeline
把这里面所用的计算和它的资源的依赖
依依次用
这个就是deck
就是一个叫有向无环图把它表达出来
然后呢
我由系统自动帮你去检查
他们彼此之间的依赖关系
自动帮你优化这些自用资源之间的
可重用的部分
比如说我发现一个buffer
其实你后面的预算就用不到了
那我就把你释放掉
然后呢在另外一个计算里面再用一下
这个东西叫什么呢
叫做aliens
就是我把这个buffer给alien过去
那么这样的一个东西的话呢
它就能够避免很多同学们犯的错误
其实这个思想我认为就是说
大家在做任何一个大型系统的时候
早期一开始一定是自己写代码
觉得我是一切尽在掌握中
当你开始跟一个大团队在一起协作的时候
你会发现啊
你的大部分时间不应该去来去想这个这个算法
每个算法怎么做
而去想一个工具
让每一个同学自己写算法的话
彼此之间不打架
那这里面举个例子
下面这张图的话呢是这个啊
如果我没记错
应该是占地四的这个它的frame graph图
大家可以看看这个图有多复杂
你展开一个很小的一个地方
它有那么多的节点
所以大家想这样的一个pipeline
如果你没有一个frame graph
这样的东西去管理的话
它是不是特别容易出错
那要出错的时候
大家想想看怎么提bug
那跟大家分享一个那个经验
就是说你在GPU上写东西
渲染的东西
你一旦挂掉之后
那是直接就GPU写的不好
现在我不知道了
以前我记得是经常可以把操作系统给刮掉的
那这个debug起来就非常头疼
所以的话呢就是frame graph这个东西的话呢
实际上是一个非常重要的一个未来的发展方向
比如说以unity为例吧
unity有两套管弦
一个叫URP
一个叫这个HDRP对吧
就是一个UP
是一个更加简单通用的rendering pip
HDRP呢是一个加了很多高端效果的
看起来高高高高高质量的
这样的一个一个一个那个就是rendering pipeline
那么这两个pipeline它下面都是用SRP去定义的
我认为这个动作就做的非常的好
所以其实呢to be honest
我觉得今天啊就是render graph
这个东西呢还不算很成熟
其实现在在行业里面大家还都在探索
就是因为接口到底怎么封装对吧
到底开放给这个graphics performer是怎么开放
到底technical artist能不能直接用
那么这里面有很多的挑战
但是的话呢这个思想我觉得大家一定可以
值得大家去了解
就是说当一个系统足够复杂
连渲染这个本身变得足够复杂的时候
我们定义了一个图形化的语言
把渲染本身的那个前后关系
依赖关系给它表达出来了
这样的话呢
才能够让我们这种超复杂的3A级游戏的开发
能够被有序地这个管理起来
基本上讲到这的话
我们的渲染这一趴就结束了
那最后呢跟同学们讲一件事情
就是你看这个故事总是没完没了
渲染我全部搞完了
我这个游戏是不是就可以做了
就可以渲染出来了
但这里面的还有最后一件事情
就是说我怎么把这个渲染
导到我的电脑屏幕上去
这里面给大家介绍一个非常大名鼎鼎的概念
叫做这个we we think
那么首先呢大家了解一个一个artifact
就是说你们不知有没有发现
就是说当我把那个就是我的游戏里面的VC
关掉之后
你会发现你的画面
特别是现在大家那种4K显示器啊
有的人会出现这种就是A画面
上下两边错开的这种这个情况
对不对
这个叫什么呢
这个学名叫screen teing
它的本质原因是什么呢
就是我们的引擎在疯狂的渲染
但是引擎的每一帧啊
它的时间是不一定的
比如说有的时候有的场景复杂的场景简单对吧
它它这个帧数有的有的时候是不一定
但是呢显示器刷新的频率是一致的
那么你那个时候如果正好好巧不巧
你正好错过了他一次刷新频率的时候
哎你这个时候就会出现你在等的这种情况
那这个的话呢
实际上就是screen tan产生的一个原因
那所谓的微信呢其实它就非常的简单
就是说他每一次都是说
你必须要把frame buffer全部写完之后
然后呢我要等到你的下一次刷新的时候
我整个frame刷新过去
而不能是你写到一半
我再刷新它
那这个时候他的画面就会出现问题
那么这里面的话呢
顺便给大家讲一个现在很流行的概念叫VR
那个VR就variable refresh rate
这个其实现在今天那个
你看那个NVIDIA和AMD都在卖钱
其实他简单的讲法就是说
哎
我能不能把你显示器的刷新频率变成动态
可调的
也就是说你的游戏按什么帧率去去渲染
我就跟你去对接在一起
这样的话我们就没有刚才大家讲的那个问题
而且呢他刚才在刚才那个微信的时候
它会产生一个问题
就是说因为我老师在等显示器的刷新频率吧
就有可能会出现就是画面就是一块块一块慢
因为你正好错过了那么一点点
这个的话呢实际上对于那种非常professional gamer
你才能注意到了
但这个地方呢我个人觉得还好
为什么呢
因为现在显示器的刷新率越来越高了
所以这个还可以
但anyway就是不妨碍大家去解决这个问题
所以这个实际上是我们写游戏引擎的最后一步
就是你要把你要渲染游戏引擎
渲染的最后一步
就是要把你渲染的东西投到我们的屏幕上去
所以讲到这一趴的话呢
基本上我们的就是游戏1104课程的渲染
这1part我们就讲完了
那么确实是现在同学们讲的
就是实际上在这个四节课里面啊
我们浓缩了几乎渲染的所有的东西
它的信息密度是非常高的
那么大家的话呢就是课程的话呢
在课程我们直播看完之后
如果听不懂没关系的
也一点都不要慌
这个真的不要慌
说实话
如果我就别说
现在就说我5年前我自己去听
我讲的这门课的话
很可能有些东西我课下还是要查查资料
去理解一下
才能明白我在讲什么东西
这也是为什么我们在准备这节课的时候
我们我经常讲解
就是我们肝都爆了
因为我们要查大量的资料
确保我们讲的东西还真的是state of art
就是说前沿的一些东西
那同学们的话呢就是千呼万唤的东西就来了
就是说哎呀这个games14课程开了这么多集了
从来不补作业
对不对
是的
因为实际上我们的压力是什么呢
就是说呃对于比如说像渲染哪
像这个就是比如说动画或者物理这种东西的话
你如果单独的做一个PTAP
其实是很简单的
但是对104呢你是游戏引擎嘛
要游戏引擎的话
那它首先是个系统
所以你会发现啊
在一个大系统里面写任何一个东西
它算法本身你去想并不难
难的是说
如何正确的把你这个算法
插入到这个引擎里面去
所以呢我们前面留了比较充足的时间
让大家去熟悉这个小引擎
那么这个时候的话呢
我们所马上我们不是说哎这节课完了之后
我们要休息一周吗
正好是五一长假
对了
五一长假大家就可以愉快的做作业了
所以这是我们的真正的作业来了
这个做这次作业做什么呢
就让大家做一个刚才讲了游戏引擎
您费效比最高的渲染技术是什么呢
是color grading
对不对
调色对吧
那么color grading的话
就让这次让大家去实践一个非自己的
color grading的算法
那我们在引擎里面加了一个post
process的一个一个框架
然后呢你把你的color grading shader
你的code把它进去
包括的话
那就是大家那个就是要想这个资源怎么去导入
怎么怎么去apply到你最终的画面上去
大家想象一下
我们小引擎的画面看上去不是很素面朝天吗
那你是不是可以把它变得非常的artistic
非常的梵高对吧
那么这就是呢我们这个这个一周多
给同学们留的作业
差不多两周时间吧
那么大家的话呢
关于这个这个作业的详细的描述的话
可以在我们的课程官网上可以下下来
那么就是说虽然我那个就是说啊
这个东西看着很简单
但实际上大家如果真的去能集成到pilot
这个小引擎的话
我个人觉得还是蛮挑战的
也是很有意思的
然后同学们的话写完之后的话呢
我们也希望同学们提供一个文档
就是告诉一下
就是描述一下你的实践思路
你的你的整个一个设计思想
包括呢提供一个截图
然后呢我们的这个就是啊助教我们的整个课程
助教团队的会帮大家一起来去给大家反馈
帮大家批改
当然看取决于我们说的作业量吧
如果作业量很大的话
我们可能批改的就稍微快一点
看看截图
简单扫扫文档
如果作业量没有那么大的话呢
那我们就给大家更详细的一点反馈
但是实话实说啊
这个东西看上去非常简单
这是我们能想到最简单的东西
但是呢你真的集成到小引擎里面的话
还是有点挑战的
比如说你要去想这个资源是怎么导进来的对吧
然后呢这个SHADER是怎么加载的对吧
然后的话呢
就是说我这个在我的渲染的那个render pipeline
刚才我们讲了我们的pipeline有deer afford对吧
那现在那小引擎最新版本是deferred rendering
那么好
那我在papa哪一趴去加上他
那包括像这个这个color grading的话
它还有很多的细节
举个例子啊
比如说你如果进去之后
把它拍成一个2D的texture
那么当你进行颜色采样的时候
你踩到每一个小色块的边界的时候
它会不会越过那个边界
对不对
那怎么办
我怎么算那个texture的UV
确保它在任何时候进行BINAR插值的时候
它不会错误地插插到边界另外一边的那个颜色
那这里面有很多的小细节
那这个就是我觉得同学们
非常值得同学们去练习
去思考的点
真的这个动作做完之后的话
你对小引擎的理解我觉得会上一个很大的档次
而这个时候大家可以真说诶
我会做游戏的渲染了
好那么顺便跟大家汇报一下
就是在过去的一周的话呢
我们小引擎又做了一些那个升级
就是最最重要的就是
我们终于把DEFRENDERING给它加上去了
这样的话我们给大家讲这个地方人类pipeline
我们最大的压力就是我们课程讲了
蒂芬内pine自己都没做
这太不好意思了
虽然一开始我们做小引擎
都想就是这个简单的框架
但是呢随着课程的进展
我们老觉得说我在课程上跟大家讲这个东西
行业里都这么做的
我们交易体没这么做
老师觉得很不好意思
然后总是给自己加料
那包括的话呢就是在那个就是上上周的话呢
我们随着同学们一直在用的话
我们也发现了很多很有意思的问题
比如说啊比如说同学们打开很多同学反映
这个小引擎跑不起来
实际上是什么原因呢
是因为笔记本电脑它有两块显卡对吧
一块70显卡
一块独显
然后呢一一个是MD的
一个是MVIDIA的
两个显显卡都在抢
都说我是爸爸
然后然后结果结果就把整个状态搞得一塌糊涂
那这些问题的话呢
其实我们后来发现了嘛
然后去修了
其实这个问题
为什么我特别喜欢跟同学们分享了
这就是做引擎的真实的状态
就是你想象一下
你做一个游戏
做一个引擎
他要支持很多游戏
然后呢要在上百万台不同配置的电脑
有的是笔记本对吧
有的是高配机
有的是很低配的电脑
有的是这个就是那个那个很4K的显示器
有的是很挫的显示器
你都要让这个东西能跑得起来
实际上这种兼容性和稳定性
才是引擎研发的工程的一个核心挑战
所以呢我也希望小引擎
一开始我们设定的目标很低嘛
但是随着同学们一起来加入
我们一起来做的时候
我们也开始慢慢慢慢的把一些很小引擎
工程感的东西
放入到我们的小引擎的这个环境里面
其实也能帮助我们所有课程的同学啊
建立一种工程的这种实践能力
我相信这种能力同学们以后走上工作岗位之后
对你会非常有帮助
那么另外一个的话呢
就是说啊
这这也是非常感谢同学们给我们反馈啊
我觉得其实我挺不好意思的
因为我们这个课程现在直播的环境呢
让我没有办法跟大家做太多的弹幕互动
那但是呢实际上同学们给我们很多反馈
我们都会在看
然后呢就是同学们普遍反映一件事情
就是小引擎的代码
大家上手还是有难度的
确实是因为说实话虽然讲讲理论都很简单对吧
那包括我后面讲了一些比较高端的引擎的东西
大家会觉得哎思想我大概都明白
但是当你真的动手去写一个引擎的时候
当你面对的几万行代码的时候
这几万行代码已经是非常非常简单了对吧
几乎是真正的一个引擎的不到1%的代码
但是的话呢实际上啊上手还是有难度的
所以我们在考虑两件事情
第一个就是说啊
这这是同学们给我的建议
因为我们本来说我们要写一个比较好的一个
spec的文档
但是同学们说你们别别忙了
你就简单告诉我们怎么看就可以了
我觉得大家说的是对的
我们先给大家准备一个相对简单的版本
可能有粗糙一点
大家原谅我们
然后呢
但是呢我们尽快的把它准备出来
然后尽量的构建我们一个wiki
方便大家去理解这个小引擎
另外一个的话呢就是我们后面还在想
就是要不要做一个
就是啊小引擎101的一个小视频
就是说101这里比如说101课程
他这就是国外的一个说法
就是说哎我教你
就是从从从简单的123怎么去勾输出
看引擎的代码
这个结构是怎么回事
因为上次我做过一次
但是呢那次只是啊非常非常简单的
这一次可能会想办法做的长一点
然后呢
帮助同学们能够
就是那个理解小引擎的代码结构
那这个视频如果我们能做好的话
到时候我们也想办法通过课程啊
通过我们B站的公众号啊
B站的那个公众号把这视频给大家
就是说大家反正在学习中
在这个小引擎的实践中
在做作业中有任何的困难的话
就那个直接告诉我们
因为我们做这个课程的话
真的是真心希望能把它做好
就是我特别怕的一件事情
就是我们花了这么多心血做的课程
结果没有帮到大家对吧
我特别开心的一件事情
就是说大家说诶我读懂了小引擎的代码
我学完了这门课
我的毕设就完美的碾压了
我身边所有没上课程的同学对吧
当我出去去做一些更复杂的工作的时候
我学这个104课程
对我建立的这个知识体系
让我一下子有很宽广的视野
对吧
那我觉得我就会非常的开心好
那最后呢就是我最开心的事情了
我们经过连续跟大家干了
这差不多快两个月了吧
那我们终于可以休息一个五一长假了
那么五一长假的话跟大家告个价
就是我们会在那个就是说5月2号那节课的话
我们会跳到5月9号
就是五一长假之后
这样的话
我们确实有更多的时间去准备下一趴的课程
因为确实是就是这个课程
准备的工作量还是蛮大的
另外一个的话呢就是大家不用担心
就是虽然在这中间的话
我们会那个就是啊课程会修修整一下
但是大家关于作业小引擎的所有的问题
我们课程组的小伙伴也会和大家积极的回答
就是说帮助大家解决大家的困难
那么就是说我们这个短暂的休整
是为了更高质量的这个给大家讲后面的课程
好的
那就非常期待同学们五一之后我们再见
那接下来的话大学有没有什么问题可以去
那个我们可以回答一下大家
啊这个同学问的问题很专业
他说刚才我讲的class brendering
在开放实践怎么划分
这个其实是他很巧妙的地方
因为它所有的划分都是用事件追了划分的
也就是说你的世界可以无限大
对不对
但是在任何一个时刻
我仍观察到的世界就是一个锥形的世界
然后呢
哎我比如设置一个100米或者500米一个锥
然后呢我就这样依次的去收集了
这个其实非常像那个呃
非常像那个理论物理里面讲的那个叫事件追
就是那个我不知道大家以前有没有看过那个
爱因斯坦假说
哎我对这个是这个宇宙是无穷大的
但是对人类来讲的话
你在实践位上
你对这个世界的感知是一个追
那个追的话
它它的半径扩张不能超过光光速
那在这个锥之外的一切对你是没有意义的对吧
其实那个cluster brendering的话
它去构建这个锥体的话
其实也是用这个思想和逻辑去做的
所以你世界再大
再开放世界
它其实也是可以的
但是这个同学的问题问的还是蛮专业的好
还有什么问题哦
render graph是吧
对对对哦
有个同学问我说
render graph到底是个高层的功能
还是个底层的功能啊
这个问题问的非常的好
其实那个虽然render graph在我们这个课程
render这个那个就是rendering
这一趴的话
最后就讲了
听起来像一个非常高级的东西对吧
但实际上的话呢
大家如果有机会参与下一代引擎的研发的话
我们会认为就是render graph
至少我个人认为这是很个人的
就是说它是一个非常底层的functionality
什么意思
就是说我们理想的话
我们希望下一代的引擎
它的绘制的基础是通过render graph的
然后呢
大家的各种各样的feature是架在这个graph上面
这样的好处
就是刚才我讲的就是在这么复杂的
就rendering pipeline的情况下
在这么多复杂的这个资源的管理和调度
在那个就是非常难以驾驭的
就是graphics SDK的情况下
我有一层中间层
把你的所有的资源的调用
硬件的接口
包括你的前后的依赖关系全部给你管理好
所以我个人认为就是说render graph
是一个底层的那个functionality
但是很就是目前的现实是说
这个概念呢提出来的年头并不久
大概可能还不到10年吧
那么其实因为就是工程上的东西是这样
就大家提出的概念觉得很棒
但是呢你真正在这个游戏引擎里面
非常的复杂的时候
其实大家也是在一步步的摸索接口该怎么定义
它的语法该怎么定义
包括就是它的资源该用什么一种语义去管理
能够既具有这种管理的一致性
又能够呢诶这个管理的这个又能够进行
具有无限的可扩张性
这就相当于你定义一种语言一样的
就像C语言
为什么今天这么难学
大家还取代不掉
就是因为它发展了20这个几十年之后啊
他的能量他能力是非常丰富的
那这种丰富度不可能是轻易的
被一个新语言就给取代掉
也是一个道理
所以我看了render graph是一个语言
是一个底层的渲染语言
啊这个同学问的就非常的专业了
他说TAA怎么去除鬼影
那说明这个同学
他其实是对这种算法是有思考和理解的
确实是ta是有鬼影的
那如果做得不好的话
实际上它会就是你会因为是这样的
就是说当我这个环境里的东西在动的时候
就是我们叫的就是parallax或者ACLUSION
发生变化的时候
实际上很多你在当前帧看到的东西
在之前真是没有的对吧
你的你的那个就是那个motion vector
它不能表达
所以呢这里面是有很多的
就是说hack
就比如说你的这个motion exture跑得太远了
我就说哎不行
你虽然理论上你说的是对的
但是我还是不信对吧
还有就是说诶你的两个颜色差别太大了对吧
就比如说你刚才这边是红的
但是我找到你的
在上一周的时候你是绿的
我说大哥
你这个有点魔幻了吧
那我也不信你了
所以说其实这里面有很多很小的trick
这个大家如果查了个论文的原文
包括它原始实践的时候
这里面都会有一大堆的很奇怪的代码
但这些dirty的代码
这些代码甚至里面还写死一些magic number
那用这种大概是这样的一个思路去去除掉贵
因为大家按这个思路去想的话
比如说它的空间位置差距过大
或者说有一些比如说其他的这种camera扩大
那我这个TA的话暂时会让他不去执行它
好的那因为今天又是成功的拖堂到两个小时了
那那个就是说我们今天的就rendering的这一趴
基本上到此结束了
那我们下一趴的话
同学们还是我讲的
就是同学们千万不要怕课程难
因为那个就是说这一节课就是帮助大家啊
这门课就是帮助大家建立
整个知识的基础体系的
那么就是说在后面的讲座中的话呢
我们也会尽可能的把这个东西讲的
就是说很明确很简单
但是呢他又让大家知道
这个行业的最重要的思想和方向是什么
所以的话呢期待大家五一之后我们再见好
谢谢大家